Gucken wir mal ob es jetzt funktioniert, eben hat es Twitch nicht gecheckt
Jetzt hat es Twitch kapiert, alles klar
Leute ich hab schon 5 Minuten mit euch geschmetzt und ich wundere mich als warum keiner reinkommt
Twitch hat einfach nicht gecheckt, dass ich online bin
Jetzt sehe ich in der Vorschau auch was, ja ok gleich
Und bei mir, ja jetzt sehe ich hier auch in der
In der App was und so, jaja gut jetzt ist ok, jede keine Ahnung fragt mich nicht was das gewesen ist
Jetzt hat es, jetzt hat Twitch das glücklicherweise auch gecheckt
Niceu
Yep, Kock
Ja Twitch hat es echt nicht gecheckt gerade, ich hab 5 Minuten schon geschmetzt
Ich hab zum Beispiel gesagt, hallo ich bin auch wieder da
Planlos und ohne was vorbereitet zu haben wie die letzten Tage auch schon
Und ich hoffe, dass ich das alles ein bisschen erledigt hätte so langsam
Weil es kann, für das, dass ich wirklich den ganzen Dezember Urlaub habe
Und eigentlich nichts machen müsste, ist ganz schön viel los
Und ich hab keine Zeit high IQ Sachen gerade vorzubereiten
Also wir können nix basteln und nix programmieren oder sonst was machen im Stream
Bin immer noch mit Job suchen und allem drum herum beschäftigt
Tja muss ich mal gucken, also ich hoffe, dass ich das ab nächster Woche dann alles ein bisschen erledigt hat
Jetzt nicht
Anderen, anderen Soundtracker
Ja, da seh ich ja
Ja so siehts aus, ich hab jetzt alles gecheckt
Ja so siehts aus, also mal gucken, dass wir ein bisschen high IQ Content produzieren die nächsten Tage
Aber ich sag, ich krieg heut nix, ich krieg heut echt nix auf die Hand
Ich bin wieder so im Arsch, Wahnsinn
Das einzige, was ich heute gemacht habe, wirklich Produktives
Ist ordentlich Mittag gegessen
Wie richtig, und es war teuer
Ich hab Gänsebraten gegessen, 25€ pro Person man, ganz schön teuer
Ja und ich hab mich um neuen Job und so Sachen gekümmert, aber das ist ja nicht wirklich produktiv
Max kann man TP vertrauen, was meinst du mit vertrauen, dass sie dort irgendeinen Backdoor haben und es nach China schicken oder vertrauen, dass sie nicht kaputt gehen
Das musst du näher spezifizieren, was du meinst
Ich vermute mal du meinst kaputt gehen, oder?
Oder?
Postchamp?
Oder nicht?
Postchampen?
Postchampen? Postchamping?
Ok, gibt keine Antwort
Ah doch jetzt
Alles vor allem, ob die China Cloud da Auge macht
Glaub ich nicht
TP-Link ist schon so oft im Einsatz, weltweit, überall
Wenn dort irgendeinen China-Chinesen standardmäßig Funk drauf wäre
Die was heimschicktes hätten schon Leute mitbekommen
Ob das natürlich Firmware-mäßig nicht irgendeinen Backdoor hat
Dass wenn das Gerät dann irgendwie manipuliert wird von irgendwie, das weiß man jetzt letztendlich nicht
Aber TP-Link ist soweit verbreitet, also ich denke da hast du ganz gute Chancen, dass nichts passiert
Im Endeffekt 100% nicht wissen kannst du natürlich nie
Solange es keine Open Source-Firmware ist
Und solange du nicht sicher weißt, dass diese Firmware auch auf dem Gerät drauf läuft, kannst du nie 100% nicht sicher sein
Aber ich denke TP-Link ist schon ok
Hab am Dienstag auch ein Vorstellungsgespräch, musst du auch nur präsent...
Du musst ne Präsentation machen im Vorstellungsgespräch?
Was musst du da präsentieren?
Erinnert mich...
Erinnert mich ein bisschen daran
Wo ich vor ganz ganz langer Zeit mich mal beworben hab um Ausbildungsplatz
Und da haben die so komische Spielchen gemacht
So stellen sie jetzt ihren Sitznachbar vor und lesen sie aufmerksam den Zettel
Und am Ende auf dem Zettel stand dann, ähm, geben sie den Zettel einfach ab
Das war so richtig cooles Zeug, Alter
Schreibst du deine Kündigung live? Ja, das machen wir heute
Leute, das machen wir heute
Das wird aber recht einfach, ich such mir ne Vorlage
Ich such mir ne Vorlage raus
Und schreib da vielleicht noch ein bisschen was um und mach noch ein Feld drunter
Erhalten oder so, fertig
Übrigens Leute, ich hab heute endlich mein Zeugnis bekommen
Das hat nur ein halbes Jahr gedauert bis ich mein Zeugnis bekommen hab
Soll ich euch mal mein Zeugnis vorlesen?
Ich muss das aber langsam machen, dass ich weder mein Name, noch Firmename, noch sonst irgendwas liege
Okay, soll ich euch mein, okay, ich lese euch, ich lese euch mein Zeugnis vor
Wobei, ich warte noch bis ein bisschen mehr Leute da sind
Ich glaube das interessiert ein bisschen mehr Leute noch, deswegen warte ich nochmal ab
So ein bisschen mehr Leute da sind
Ja, ansonsten, wie gesagt
Ich hab ja eigentlich neue Stelle
Und ich hab auch den Vertrag schon losgeschickt
Was macht das zweite Jobangebot?
Naja, das erste, zweite liegt auf Eis, die waren zu langsam
Da werd ich auch kein Video drüber machen
Lustigerweise hat sich am Freitag noch ein anderer ehemaliger Kollege gemeldet
Und hat gemeint, Max, komm doch zu uns
Und die sind in Frankfurt
Und die bieten einfach mal, und jetzt halt, jetzt haltet's euch, jetzt haltet euch fest
Die bieten mit Bonus und allem auf fünf Tage gerechnet über 30.000 Euro mehr als die anderen
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Richtig, richtig stonks, ja
Es ist auch in Frankfurt, nicht in Würzburg
Und es ist halt ne Bank
Und wie ich schon oft gesagt habe, Banken stehen auf Finanzbranchen-Erfahrung
So, ich bin froh, dass der Vertrag noch nicht angekommen ist bei den anderen
Die Scheiße ist jetzt nur
Ich hab den eigentlich schon zugesagt
Aber ich bin froh, dass der Vertrag noch nicht angekommen ist bei den anderen
Die Scheiße ist jetzt nur
Ich hab den eigentlich schon zugesagt
Und ich finde die auch unglaublich nett bisher
Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich die Personalabteilung tatsächlich nett finde
Und die haben sich alle so gefreut
Ich mich eigentlich auch
Ich weiß echt nicht, was ich jetzt machen soll
Was ist denn das für ein Quatsch?
Ja, hast du schon den Sohn, hast schon recht
Aber auf der anderen Seite, hey, ich mein
Der Unterschied ist halt
Auch recht viel Homeoffice
Halt in Frankfurt
Und bis zu
Oder was heißt bis zu, je nachdem
Ich hab ja mit denen noch das gar nicht jetzt final ausgemacht
Circa 30.000 Euro auf 5 Tage gerechnet mehr
Für mich ist es dann natürlich nicht so
Aber das ist halt schon ne krasse Hausnummer
Die Branche ist richtig wild, ja
Ich glaube, es kann mir im Endeffekt keiner übel nehmen
Wenn das einfach
Was willst du machen?
Stripes, Dankeschön
Für den Sub, 50 Milliarden Monate, ja
Wo sei ich? Michael, 50 Milliarden, den hab ich auch schon lange nicht gesehen
Sag es niemand
Ich muss ja wenn schon absagen
Ich hab richtig Bauchschmerzen dabei
Eigentlich will ich das gar nicht
Weil die waren wirklich nett
Und das Team, die Leute waren top
Ich weiß echt nicht, was ich machen soll
Ja, das muss ich noch rauskriegen
Eigentlich will ich
Vielleicht geh ich auch einfach zu den anderen
Wo ich eh schon einen Vertrag jetzt hab
Ist wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung
Warum hätten die sich das nicht alle mal ein paar Monate vorher überlegen können
Nee, nee, nee, die haben schon das maximale
Bei den anderen hab ich schon das maximale
Und das glaub ich denen auch
Ja, ich mein, wird nicht anders da übrig bleiben
Aber eigentlich will ich ja gar nicht
Absagen, das ist halt die Sache
Die haben mich tatsächlich von ihrer Art überzeugt
Ich fand die wirklich nett
Und auch die Leute dort, wo ich dann arbeite
Die Personalabteilung und alle
Ja, will ich ja gar nicht
Ich will ja gar nicht
Irgendwie jetzt jeder
Chromo Sachen treiben
Was, woraus gekommen ist
Also aktuell ist die Job-Suche bei mir folgendermaßen aus
Ich werd kündigen Ende des Jahres
Und ich hab einen neuen Job in Würzburg
Die haben mir auch schon einig
Die haben mir einen Vorabvertrag per Mail geschickt
Und jetzt den nächsten Vertrag per Post
Ist auf dem Weg
Die Unterschiede sind
Glaube ich rein Mitarbeiter
Anzahltechnisch
Gar nicht so unterschiedlich
Aber die Branchen sind unterschiedlich
Also beide Unternehmen haben weit über 2000 Mitarbeiter
Willst du dann deinen alten Arbeitgeber leaken
Weiß ich nicht, was haben wir davon
Vielleicht werd ichs mal erwähnen
Was es ging, ja
Wie lange hast du Zeit den Vertrag zu...
Da ist kein Countdown drauf
Aber eigentlich will ich die nicht versetzen
Ja das stimmt schon
Ja gut, in der Lage war ich glücklicherweise noch nie
Ist der Job in Würzburg Homeoffice only
Mehr oder weniger
Einmal im Monat muss ich hin
Zu so nem
Rücksprache mit meinem Chef
Rest des Homeoffice
Also ich hab ein Angebot
Das ist schon so weit, dass ich den Vertrag
Mehr oder weniger vorliegen habe
Und halt noch eins
Was jetzt quasi auf allerletzten Drücker reingekommen ist
Das neue wahrscheinlich mit Bonus über 100k
Auf 5 Tage gerechnet
Wie gesagt, das muss man mal 0,8 nehmen
Für Teilzeit
Aber
Das ist echt schwierig gerade
Ich hab echt Bauchschmerzen
Falls das andere klappt
Dass ich mal in so ner Lage bin, Alter
Dass die sich ja auch mal
Kloppen um einen hätte ich nicht gedacht
Was heißt nicht gedacht
Doch hätte ich schon gedacht
Aber ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass ich mal
In der Situation bin
Da kann der Chat ausnahmsweise nicht helfen
Ja, weil der Chat normalerweise auch bei allen
Immer 100% hilfreich ist
Wobei man sagen muss, tatsächlich mein Chat
Ist ja ausnahmslos hauptsächlich
Ausnahmslos
Tatsächlich mein Chat ist ja ausnahmslos
HiRQ
Mein Chat ist tatsächlich hilfreich
Java? Nein, kein Java
Also ich kann euch ja mal sagen, was die unterschiedlichen sind
Also
Das in Würzburg, wo ich den Vertrag
Hier schon quasi vorliegen habe
Ist
Ich überleg grad, wie ist die Stelle nochmal
Linux System Engineer
Senior Linux System Engineer
Oder sowas in der Richtung
Und da gehts hauptsächlich um
Kontenarisierung
Klassische Linux-Administration
Automatisierung
Und
So relativ klassische Geschichten
Und das andere
Was ich noch am Start hätte
Ist auch
In diese Richtung, allerdings
Etwas mehr
Noch Richtung
Google Cloud, Azure Cloud und
Im Detail muss ich das genau
Muss ich mir das alles mal genau erklären lassen
Glücklicherweise habe ich in meine Skillliste
Google Cloud geschrieben
Das scheint denen gefallen zu haben
Dabei muss ich sagen
Habe ich mit Azure mehr Ahnung als
Google Cloud
Allerdings
Bin ich wenigstens nicht komplett
Ahnungslos
Ehrlich gesagt, ich mach mir ums Geld normalerweise
Wenig Gedanken
Aber jetzt ist halt so die Phase
Wo es mal sinnvoll ist
Sich ums Geld Gedanken zu machen
Weil jetzt bin ich halt in so einer
Entscheide, normalerweise mach ich mir da keine Gedanken drüber
Also Leute, seriously
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, ja
Ich bin eh der Meinung, wenn man
Über eine gewissen Gehaltsgrenze ist
Sodass man gut von leben kann
Dass man auch ein bisschen was zur Seite legen kann
Sodass im Prinzip quasi
Das mehr wird auf dem Konto
Oder bei der Anlage und nicht quasi
Im Monat immer Minus ist im Konto
Und man gewisse
Gehaltsgrenze überschritten hat
Ich finde
Dann macht es gar nicht mehr so einen riesen Unterschied
Solange man zufrieden
Und happy mit der Arbeit ist
Also
Ob du jetzt
Jetzt mal ernsthaft
Also ob du jetzt zum Beispiel 70.000 Euro
Verdienst im Jahr
Oder 90.000 Euro im Jahr
Natürlich macht das einen Unterschied
Auf spätestens auf ein Bankkonto
Oder auch wenn du investieren willst
Oder wenn du selbst vorsorgen willst
Was auch immer
Aber
Für mich würde ich sagen
Ab
Dieser Schwelle von ungefähr
70.000 Euro
Wiegt
Geld selbstverständlich immer noch am meisten
Weil Gehalt mit das
Wichtigste ist
Dass halt man arbeiten geht
Aber es wiegen andere Sachen finde ich
Mehr als vorher
Weil da bist du über diese
Wo du dir Gedanken machen musst
Wenn du 70.000 Euro
Im Jahr verdienst
Gut davon kommt natürlich nicht alles an
Weil Steuern und so
Wenn du ein Gehalt hast von 70.000 Euro im Jahr
Dann kannst du mehr oder weniger
Alles machen was du willst
Du musst nicht großartig sparen
Sag mal so und das was du nicht machen kannst
Mit 90 oder 100.000 Euro im Jahr auch nicht machen
Da musst du nicht großartig sparen
Du kannst dir eigentlich mehr oder weniger
Alles kaufen was du willst
Du kannst auch in Urlaub fahren wenn du willst
Du kannst auch öfters mal größere Investitionen
Tätigen was du willst
Und danach
Ist halt deutlich wichtiger finde ich
Dass man eben noch
Andere Dinge
Dass man halt einfach happy ist
Aber
Ja ich weiß ich weiß
Ich hab halt
Ich bin halt in einer guten Position
Dass sowohl mein Skillset als auch meine
Erfahrung
In dem Job
Begehrt ist gerade
Aber ja genau was ich eigentlich sagen wollte
Deswegen wenn ich das dann erstmal dort
Dann mach ich mir dementsprechend über das Geld
Gar nicht so viel Gedanken
Ich mach mir jetzt über das Geld nicht so viele Gedanken
Ich mach mir beim neuen Job über das Geld nicht so viele Gedanken
Und ich mach mir dann
Bei dem vielleicht anderen Job nicht so viele Gedanken
Weil ich bin jetzt einfach
Über diese Schwelle drüber
Wo ich auch für mich gemerkt hab
Das reicht halt einfach für alles was ich machen will
Ich bin niemand
Der viel Geld ausgibt
Also ich kauf mir ab
Leute ich weiß klingt jetzt doof
Ich hab mir ein Auto gekauft
Vor ein paar Monaten
Jetzt den fetten Rechner
Das ist aber wirklich eine Ausnahme
Normalerweise gebe ich so gut wie nichts aus
Ich kauf mir
Alle 5 Jahre mal einen Rechner
Ansonsten gebe ich fast nichts aus
Und
Ich hab halt einfach
Für mich gemerkt
Dass wenn ich über diese Grenze so drüber bin
Da mach ich mir da keine Gedanken
Ich kann mir die Sachen kaufen die ich kaufen will
Das reicht mir
Dann ist mir viel viel lieber
Dass so Sachen wie Homeoffice geregelt sind
Dass Teilzeitmöglichkeiten
Und sowas bestehen
Dass die Leute nett sind
Dass man mit der Personalabteilung klarkommt
Dass man sich nicht permanent beefed
Mit irgendwelchen Leuten auf der Arbeit
Das ist mir dann viel mehr
Viel mehr wert als
Ähm
Noch ein bisschen mehr Geld
Was ja auch der Grund
Ok Leute ich geb zu
Vielleicht würde ich anders denken
Wenn ich Frau und Kinder hätte
Oder sagen wir Frau und Kinder
Zeichnen sich ab
Wenn sie ein Haus kaufen will
Und das abbezahlen müssen
Da würd ich vielleicht ganz anders denken
Ich kann das so immer aus
Meiner Situation jetzt beschreiben
Und natürlich nicht allgemeingültig
Für mich ist das so
Und für mich ist es halt so
Ich hab gemerkt
Ich hab einfach genug Kohle
Und da kommt's nicht
So krass drauf an
Das heißt ich wäre tatsächlich
Bereit
Da Abstriche zu machen
Solange der Rest halt super ist
Naja
Ja
Genau also Würzburg
Mit Würzburg bin ich mir schon einig
Würzburg hab ich eigentlich auch gesagt
Passt alles schickt mir den Vertrag
Das war auch bis letzte Woche alles so
Das andere dritte Angebot wo ich letzte Woche
Vorstellungsgespräch oder Gespräch mit denen hatte
Die sind einfach viel zu langsam
Das ist so ein richtiger Boomerladen
Das hab ich schon gleich gemerkt
Die bezahlen zwar gut die haben zwar gleich gesagt
In ihrer Stellenanzeige 90 bis 100
105k
Aber
Das ist so ein richtiger Boomerladen
Das hab ich gleich gemerkt also
Die brauchen für alles ewig
Und mit Durchschlag am besten auch per Fax
Also ist nix
Ja und das andere
Das allerletzten Drücker
Ist halt auch ein Ex-Kollege der mich angeschrieben hat
Auf dem Handy
Und hat gesagt hier Max willst du nicht zu uns
Der arbeitet auch bei einer Bank in Frankfurt
Und ist tatsächlich
Von aktuell wo ich arbeite
Nur ein paar Meter weg
Gut Frankfurt Banken Viertel ist alles ein paar Meter weg
Das kam jetzt halt
Echt auf den letzten Drücker mann
Ja
Also aktuell bin ich
Bei einer Bank
Das andere Angebot ist von einer Bank
Und das wo ich
Mir schon einig bin mit den
Conditions
Conditions das kann man gar nicht sagen
Auf Deutsch so
Also mit den Konditionen
Wo ich den Vertrag auch schon da hab
Da wo ich eigentlich
Hin will
Das ist keine Bank
Das ist
Sag ich euch nicht
Nein nein
Es ist nicht im Erotik Sektor
Oder so weil ich es euch nicht sage
Nein nein das ist was ganz normales
Außer wer ist schlimm
Gatschi Bass ist doch heutzutage auch kein Problem
Aber sag ich euch
Weil ihr wisst das in Würzburg ist da kann man denke ich
Wenn ich das sage
Komm ich jetzt schon relativ einfach danach googeln
Und dann wird man es rausfinden
Das Haus muss nicht bezahlt werden
Das Haus hat mal irgendwann meinen Opa gebaut
Mein Bauchgefühl sagt
Mehr Geld
So doof es klingt
Vor allem ist es halt so viel mehr Geld
Das ich sagen würde ey
Ja
Wenn es nicht so viel mehr Geld wäre
Würde ich es gar nicht in Erwägung ziehen
Ey sag das mal dem Krankenpfleger alter 70k ist nichts
Leute
Vielleicht muss ich das an der Stelle nochmal sagen
Ich rede immer von mir
Ich bin wirklich froh
Dass wir Leute haben
Auch in anderen Berufen
Die das machen
Und gewissenhaft machen
Ich wüsste beispielsweise gar nicht
Was ich machen würde wenn ich zum Beispiel als ich mit meiner Mutter im Krankenhaus war
Wenn da keine Leute sind
Und ich würde mir auch gerade für die wünschen
Dass sie mal angemessen Geld bekommen
Wenn wir hier immer die
Die fetten Zahlen um uns schmeißen
Und selbst das ist ja nicht fett
Wenn man mal in die
Guck mal zu Microsoft oder so
Aber
Ich bin wirklich froh dass das Leute machen
Und ich wünsche mir für die Leute auch dass es da mal ordentlich Kohle für gibt
Es kann nämlich nicht sein
Dass du im Prinzip einen viel
Wichtigeren und vor allem
Verantwortungsvolleren Job machst
Sagen wir im Krankenhaus
Wie das was ich mache
Und dafür nur die Hälfte an Geld kriegst
Du hast körperliche Belastung
Du hast psychische Belastung
Du hast scheiß Arbeitsbedingungen
Und du verdienst noch nicht mal viel Geld
Also ich
Also es ist wirklich
Unglaublich dass es nur Leute gibt die das machen
Und die müssten meiner Meinung nach viel mehr kriegen
Und ja ich weiß bei uns in Deutschland
Ist es halt nun mal so
Und wahrscheinlich wenn ich einen unserer Manager
Fragen würde
Was ist wichtiger
Ähm
Ob einer im Krankenhaus nicht stirbt
Auf der Notaufnahme
Oder ob unser System weiter läuft
Und wir nicht 15 Millionen verlieren
Was meint ihr was der als Antwort sagt
Na doch ich kann euch sagen was er als Antwort sagt
Er wird er wird offiziell sagen
Selbstverständlich dass er in der Notaufnahme nicht stirbt
Aber zwischen
Manager Kollegen wird er natürlich ganz klar
Sagen dass wir 15 Millionen
Verdienen
Ist ja klar
Ist ja logisch
Offiziell wird er es nicht sagen aber er wird es sich auf jeden Fall denken
Also bei uns
Geht es halt in der Finanzbranche geht es halt
Immer um sehr viel Geld
Auch was Verfügbarkeit der Systeme angeht
Was neue Produkte angeht
Und sonst es geht immer um unglaublich viel Geld
Aber es geht bei uns halt nie wirklich
Um Leben und Tod
Das ist das was ich auch immer sage
Ähm wenn sie bei uns
Wieder riesige Panik schieben
Oder
Hier stirbt doch grad keiner
Ja
Aber ähm
Letztendlich
Ja
Ja Onlinepolizei finde man kann das gar nicht so wirklich
Vergleichen
Weil das ist immer die Frage
Wen lässt du das bewerten
Ja
Für irgendwelche random Leute die du nicht kennst
Ist dir das vollkommen egal
Wenn du die
Wenn du die kennst dann siehst du es ganz anders
Letztendlich ist ja der Vergleich
Ist ja der Vergleich auch Blödsinn
Aber bei uns geht es halt um massig Geld
Dementsprechend bezahlen
Die halt auch übelst übelst
Viel Kohle und da steckt halt viel Geld drinne
Aber an den Stellen wo es was ich halt sagen will ist
An den Stellen wo es halt wirklich um Leben
Und Tod geht da ist halt aktuell
Scheiß Arbeitsbedingungen
Geldmäßig nicht so der Wahnsinn
Ähm starke Belastungen sowohl
Körperlich psychisch als auch teilweise
Von der Belastung von Arbeitszeiten her
Also ganz im Ernst im Krankenhaus
Altenpflege
Krankenschwester
Krankenpflege und sowas in der Richtung
Ich verstehe nicht warum es aktuell
Für das Geld und die Arbeitsbedingungen überhaupt einer macht
Ich bin sehr froh dass es
Leute gibt die das machen und ich wünsche
Denen dass es tatsächlich da
Nicht nur mehr Geld gibt
Und nicht
Nur mehr Anerkennung gibt
Weil ganz ehrlich von Anerkennung
Alleine bezahlt die Hütte nicht
Ja könnt ihr ja noch daran erinnern
Wozu Corona Zeiten vom
Klapper Klapper
Vom Balkon gemacht wurde oder sowas
Oder im Supermarkt gesagt wurde die Kassierer
Sind unsere Helden und sowas wo ich mir
Auch gedacht habe wenn das wirklich eure Helden
Sind dann macht halt mal 150
Millionen locker und verteilt die
Aber anscheinend sind die nicht Helden genug
Die müssen gefällig
Zufrieden sein mit ein bisschen klatschen
Und ähm warmem
Händedruck ja
Wenn man sich jetzt sieht gerade
In letzten in letzten Wochen
Wie schnell Millionen und
Milliarden locker gemacht werden aber dafür
Für die Leute hat man natürlich kein Geld
Ja
Und da müsste wirklich da müsste sich wirklich
Was tun und wie gesagt
Nicht nur deswegen würde ich nicht
Nicht nur mehr Geld, was ich denen vor allen wünsche
Ist dass es
Ordentliche Arbeitsbedingungen
Wieder gibt und ordentliche Arbeitsbedingungen
Resultieren aus mehr Personal
Und dementsprechend mehr Geld
Und da sieht es ja leider aktuell nicht drauf aus
Ich kenne ein paar
Zwei Ecken
Die im Krankenhaus gearbeitet haben
Und die sind alle weg mittlerweile komplett
Ja richtig sad getimed
Ab einer gewissen Summe wird man
Wieder unglückselt tatsächlich
Okay die habe ich noch nicht erreicht
Das verstehe ich nicht
Überfordert heißt ja
Das ist ein Aufgabenbereich wo du
Nicht in der Lage bist
Deiner
IQ technisch
Oder überhaupt technisch nicht in der Regel bist
Nicht in der Lage bist
Die Arbeit zu machen
Wir schreiben heute die Kündigung im Stream
Easy
Ich kopiere mir
Eine Vorlage
Aber ich muss sie noch ergänzen
Um ein Feld erhalten am
Oder sowas
Zeugnisvorlesen, stimmt
Rolli schön dass du deinen Weg her gefunden hast
Habe ich irgendwas übersehen
Was du vorher geschrieben hast
Das ist nämlich so der Eindruck als ist er gleich wieder weg
Na gut
Ja
Überall
Das ist krass sie suchen mega dringend überall
Leute
Nee
Also
Ich möchte kein hauptberuflicher
Software Entwickler sein
Nee
Kündigungen müssen immer schriftlich
Passieren immer
So in beide Richtungen
Also ich möchte nicht als hauptberuflicher Software Entwickler
Arbeiten
Und Automobilindustrie bedeutet wahrscheinlich
Viel Embedded Zeug was wiederum
C++ bedeutet
Und das muss nicht sein
Da mache ich mich vom Acker
Welches Auto ist gekauft nicht geliest
Nee nicht geliest
Die hat 500e
Da gibt es eine Story zu
Ich weiß nicht ne die erzähle ich nicht
Die erzähle ich nicht
Oh das kann ich dir nicht
Nein das kann ich dir nicht erzählen
Das kann ich dir nicht erzählen
Nee keine Booba Story
Andere
Andere Körperregionen
Das ist richtig cringe Leute
Nee das erzähle ich nicht
Nein nein das erzähle ich nicht
Außerdem war das nicht HR
Okay ganz kurz
Wenn ich so also
Okay okay
Die Kurzfassung
Als ich noch in der
Ausbildung war hat man Azubis bei uns gerne rumgeschickt
In Technikräumen im Haus
Felix und ich wir waren auch die einzigen
Die noch in Technikräume reingepasst haben
Weil wir nicht so fett waren
Und noch an Switchen vorbeigekommen sind
Um die Kabel rauszureißen
Also man hat Azubis damals gerne
Durchs Haus rumgeschickt
Und
Tja
Dosen überprüfen lassen
Switches ausprobieren
Switches einbauen lassen und sowas in der Richtung
Und wir waren
Wie gesagt das war noch die Zeit wo wir beim Provider gewesen sind
Und wir sollten mal wieder
Irgendwelche Kabel überprüfen
Und wir sollten auch dafür sorgen, dass die neuen IP Telefone
Ordentlich angeschlossen sind
Und booten
Die müssen dann DHCP sich eine Adresse holen
Und dann brauchen die irgendwie noch einen zweiten
Irgendwie so einen zweiten Server
Wo die ihre Firmware ziehen können
Und jetzt zumindest
Darauf raus
Dass wir bei den Leuten
Ins Büro sind
Und haben halt gesagt
Wir sind hier für das neue Telefon
Anschließen und sowas und haben das heißt
Zumindest
Lange Rede kurzer Sinn
Ich bin mal eine unter den Tisch gekrabbelt
Und hab gesehen, dass sie keine Hose anhat
Also keine Unterwäsche anhat
Und da hab ich so geguckt
Und ich
Ich hab keine Ahnung ob die das
Ob das Absicht war
Oder ob sie nicht dran gedacht hat oder so
Weil ich mein die hätte ja einfach aufstehen können
Und nicht setzen bleiben
Und das hat mich äußerst verstört
Und ja
Vielleicht fand die das toll
Dass die Azubis
Ihr unter den Rock gucken konnten
Keine Ahnung Alter
Oh man
Ich bin dann echt
Ich bin so schnell raus
War die hot
Ich kanns dir nicht genau sagen
Ich hab die nicht richtig angepasst
Ich hab die nicht richtig angeguckt
Danach als ich unter dem Tisch raus bin
Ich bin einfach weg
Ich bin ganz schnell geflüchtet Alter
Okay das war 2008 oder so
Trotzdem
Ich hab mir
Leute
Ich hab jetzt nicht super
Gestarrt oder so
Ich hab halt
Unter dem Tisch das Zeug angeschlossen
Und guck halt hoch
Und auf einmal
Was ist jetzt los
Und ich hab halt versucht
Nach Möglichkeiten
Einfach weiter den Kram anzuschließen
Ich wollte ja auch nicht
Merk dass es mir aufgefallen ist
Oh man
Das war was ich sag's euch
War es das erste Mal wenn du verstehst
Dass sowas passiert ist ja
Das ist danach auch nie wieder passiert
Also ich kann euch nicht sagen
Wie gesagt ich hab die kaum angeguckt
Die dürfte aber
Die war auf jeden Fall schon ein bisschen älter
Was ich
Alte gewesen ist aber auf jeden Fall
Deutlich älter als ich
Also ich mein
Das war in meiner
Ausbildung da war ich lass mal überlegen
Da war ich 24
Und
Die ist
Wahrscheinlich 20 Jahre älter
War auf jeden Fall
Ein Tanzverbot
Genau richtig
Egal
Genug von solchen
Stories
Das hat mich ein wenig
Traumatisiert ja
Und ich frag mich bis heute noch
Ob das Absicht war
Ich
Ich wein
Die hätte aufstehen können
Baust du auch
Einen neuen PC habe ich gesehen auf Twitter
Aber jetzt nicht
Heute hier
Wo ist es denn
Ich hab erst den
Komm her Kiste
Heute mach ich eigentlich nur Stream
Dass ich mich ein bisschen beruhigen kann nach dem Stress
Am ganzen Tag
Also ich hab bisher erst das Mainboard da
Den Kühler
Die SSD
Und den Kontakt Frame
Aber der ist in der anderen Kiste
Ich werd wahrscheinlich erst am Wochenende
Wenn alles da ist den Kram zusammenbauen
Aber dann on stream
Und dann bin ich mal gespannt ob das alles hinhaut
Ob ich nichts kaputt mache
Welche Grafikkarte
Warte mal ich mach mal
Wie geht denn das hier
Haben wir das schon drinnen
Ausrufezeichen PC
Da müsste man eigentlich
Einen Link haben
Genau das ist
Ist das die neu
Das ist die letzte Zusammenstellung
Das ist genau das was ich bestellt hab
Also hier mit
Ich hab auch mega Bock
Schon das Ding zusammenzubauen
Aber ich bin ja bekannt für das mal ab und zu im Stream was raucht
Oder abraucht
Ich hoffe nicht weil egal welches Teil
Hier abraucht das ist auf jeden Fall
Zu teuer zum abrauchen
Und die Grafikkarte hat keinen tieferen
Sinn das ist einfach weil die
verfügbar war gerade
Da kommt wieder das 11 drauf chat
Da kommt wieder das 11 drauf
Ich weiß nicht von was du
Spricht keine Ahnung
ESD Schutz
Hab ich
Ich hab so nen
Armband
Wir legen uns das Armband
Umschließen es nirgendswo an
Achja ich wollt euch ja mein Zeugnis vorlesen
Ok das muss ich jetzt versuchen
Zu anonymisieren also Leute
Passendes
Ambiente für anmachen
Ich scroll mal schnell den Chat durch
Bevor wir das machen
Hast du Tipps für
Quereinsteiger
Hab ich Tipps für Quereinsteiger
Du musst Ahnung haben
Das ist aber ein Tipp den ich für alle hab
In nem Gebiet was gesucht wird
Das kann tatsächlich sowas gestörtes sein wie
Kobol
Es kann aber auch natürlich Azure, Google Cloud
AWS oder sonstige Geschichten
Sein von Kontinuerisierung
Linux meinetwegen auch Windows und sonst was
Wenn es halt gesucht wird
Wichtig ist du musst dich halt auskennen
Es reicht nicht das du einfach nur ein bisschen IT
Wizards durchklicken kannst
Du musst dich halt wirklich auskennen
Und halt einen finden der jemand sucht
Der das kann was du weißt
Ist im Prinzip relativ easy
Weil die suchen wie verrückt Leute
Die suchen wie verrückt Leute
Also ich denke die Quereinsteiger
Chancen sind so gut wie nie
Massive 36 Monate
Hypersubscription
Das ist ja nice
Elrisitas ist mein Held
Meine auch
Elrisitas Chat
Das ist die Könige
Ok
Ne warte mal
Wie ist denn die Adresse davon?
Ihr wisst das doch bestimmt
Chatopenai.com
Wir lassen uns eine Kündigung davon schreiben
Machen wir gleich
Wie gesagt ich lese euch vorher noch mal schnell mein Zeugnis vor
Hab ich ja gesagt mach ich
Kündigungen müssen nicht formal sein
Aber Kündigungen müssen
Immer schriftlich sein
Und so ein paar Sachen
Sind natürlich ganz nützlich
Zum Beispiel wenn
Klar gesagt wird
Wann
Dass du quasi schnellstmöglich reinschreibst und sowas
Wo neue Rechner
Neue Rechner liegt zum Teil schon hinter mir
Hat Max eine neue Stelle
Ja hab ich hab den Vertrag
Wie ich
Wie gesagt immer immer schriftlich
Das ist das einzige was ich mir in der Berufsschule gemerkt hab
Wenn es um dieses Thema geht
Kündigung immer schriftlich
Das heißt wenn euch euer Chef kündigt mündlich
Dann gilt das gar nicht
Dann kommt ihr einfach morgen wieder zur Arbeit
Also wenn der Chef zu euch kommt
Und sagt ihr übrigens hier Alchemist
Ich werf dich raus
Dann kommst du einfach morgen wieder zur Arbeit
Ja
Für die Wirksamkeit der Kündigungen ist eine Annahme
Unter Bestätigung des Erklärungsempfängers
Nicht notwendig
Ja ja das kann schon sein
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall von Vorteil
Dass sie nicht sagen können sie wissen von nichts
Ich hab schon Probetag
In dem Sinn gab es nicht aber ich war schon vor Ort
Und hab das Team kennen gelernt
Und wir haben uns auch gut verstanden
Das hab ich ja erst gesagt passt alles
Kannst du den Bankensektor als Attiler empfehlen?
Ja
Wenn du Geld verdienen willst auf jeden Fall
Wenn du
Flexibilität
Na Flexibilität kann ich sagen
Wenn du was
Modernes willst
Ohne langwierige Prozesse
Und fünfmal im Kreis gedrehe
Und alles mit vier Augen absegnen lassen
Dann ist vielleicht Bankensektor nichts für dich
Also Bankensektor ist schon ziemlich
Boomer Style und gewachsen
Zumindest alles was ich bisher gesehen hab
축
Hey, umgedreht wärs das auf jeden Fall gewesen.
Mit wieviel Jahren hast du eigentlich deine Ausbildung beendet?
Mit 25 oder so?
Also meine zweite Ausbildung wohlgemerkt.
Die erste hab ich ja nie beendet.
Was ich mit auskennen meine, dass du dich auskennst halt, wie soll ich auskennen definieren,
dass du ein fundiertes, fachliches, tiefgreifende Kenntnisse in einem Themengebiet hast, was
halt gesucht wird.
Beziehungsweise was halt zueinander passt.
Dass du, zum Beispiel, wenn du in der Lebenslauf schreibst, Vmware, dass du nicht mal ein Ubuntu
in Vmware Workstation installiert hast, sondern auch wirklich Erfahrung hast im Betrieb mit
einem ESX Cluster.
Und dich auch ein bisschen auskennst, wie Vmware so tickt, auch schon mal mit dem Vmware
Support was zu tun hat, weißt, auf welche Einstellungen es ankommt, was so best practices
dafür sind, was Vmware empfiehlt, was die für Anforderungen haben und so, dass du dich
halt auskennst.
Was ich vom Abwärtstrend halte, eigentlich ist das ziemlich egal, es gibt genug Leute,
die weiterhin, also es gibt genug offene Stellen und ob da Microsoft, Facebook, sonst
wie die, ich glaube, dass es auf die Gesamtheit nicht so viel Auswirkungen hat, ehrlich gesagt.
Die haben halt auch massig Leute immer angeheuert und die hatten ja auch tausende Bewerber
bisher immer und konnten sich da auch immer die Besten rauspicken.
Es ist aber jetzt auch schon so, dass viele Leute gar nicht länger als 1-2 Jahre dort
geblieben sind.
Die durchschnittliche Arbeitsdauer bei Googlen und Konsorten ist ja irgendwie eineinhalb
zwei Jahre, die bleiben ja alle nicht lange da.
Ich glaube, dass es unterm Strich jetzt keine große Auswirkung für uns hat.
Hast du deine Skill-Liste schon veröffentlicht, ja, hier, irgendwo.
Das ist mehr oder weniger die Skill-Liste, die ich da auch hingeschickt habe, aber nicht
exakt, weil ein paar Sachen habe ich noch umsortiert, also die Finale habe ich noch
von irgendwo gezeigt.
Was denkst du über das Snowflake Browser Plugin?
War das irgendwas mit Kryptowährungen?
Ach nee, das ist anonymes Browsen, weiß ich, habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Das ist tatsächlich bei mir auch so gewesen, allerdings nicht der klassische Trend, ich
war ja bei meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb, danach noch ein Jahr gearbeitet und dann bin ich
gewechselt dorthin, wo ich jetzt immer noch bin und ich bin jetzt 10 Jahre, eigentlich
sind es mehr, weil das Probejahr und so, das zähle ich mal alles, lassen wir das mal weg,
aber ich bin 10 plus Jahre jetzt schon bei der Bank, wo ich jetzt arbeite.
Als den ersten Arbeitgeber habe ich relativ schnell gewechselt, den zweiten habe ich ewig
jetzt durchgezogen und jetzt ist es soweit, dass ich was Neues suche, eigentlich schon
was Neues gefunden habe.
So, ich habe es geschafft, ok Leute, ich lese euch jetzt mein Zeugnis vor, also, Herr Max,
ich muss das langsam lesen, dass ich nichts liege, ne, falsche Seite habe ich angefangen,
Herr Max, geboren am, ist seitdem bla bla bla, als Mitarbeiter in unserem Unternehmen tätig,
die bla bla bla bla bla bla bla erbringt für die bla bla bla bla bla bla, Unterstützende
und bla bla bla bla bla bla, ok das ist alles egal, das ist zu spezifisch um was es geht,
also, Herr Max, war bis zum, ok, ich lasse das da hinweg, November 2017 im Bereich Betriebserver,
bla bla bla bla, tätig, hier übernahm er nachstehende Tätigkeiten, DevOps, ich weiß
nicht, ob die das nicht richtig durchgelesen haben bei der Perso, aber ok, DevOps, Versionsverwaltung
scripting, Puppet, Git, Puppet, nochmal doppelt, weiß ich, was sie da geschrieben haben, Ruby
Scripts, Planung und Koordination, Teamdokumentation, Confluence, Confluence Automatisierung mittels
groovy scripts, Ansprechpartner für bla bla bla bla bla bla, Fehleranalyse, Beratung,
Unterstützung, Paketierung, Release Management, Planung, Koordination, Automatisierung und
Abstimmung, Hotfixes, Merchrequests, Fehleranalyse, Testen, Qualifizierung, Verteilen von Fehlerreports,
Ähm, geht noch weiter, geht noch weiter. Aufgrund einer Umstrukturierung des gesamten
IT Bereichs wurde Herr Max zum bla bla bla bla bla, in die Abteilung bla bla bla bla
zugeordnet, hier übernimmt er, hier übernahmt er wesentlich die folgenden Aufgaben, DevOps,
Ich weiß nicht, warum das als einzelner Punkt dahinter steht, aber okay, DevOps, Git, GitHub,
Bitbucket, GitLab, Continuous Integration, Continuous Delivery, Release Management für
über 3000 Linux-Systeme, Infrastructure as Code, Automatisierung, Puppet, Ansible, Bash,
Ruby, Groovy, Python, Scripting, Let's Encrypt, passt an der Stelle zwar überhaupt nicht hin,
aber okay, Let's Encrypt halt, ja. Linux System Engineering, Red Hat, Ubuntu,
Hochverfügbarkeit, Ausfallsicherheit, Security, Kontinuerisierung und Skalierung,
Toolentwicklung, C-Sharp.net, Go, JavaScript, ich hab da noch viel mehr reingeschrieben eigentlich,
aber okay, technische Dokumentation, Confluence, Konzeption und Einführung der neuen technischen
Dokumentation für Linux-Systeme, inklusive Daily Import der Daten aus CMDB und Azure.
Der Zeugnisanteil kommt auf der zweiten Seite. Etablierung und Umsetzung eines Infrastructure
as Code Release-Verfahrens für alle Linux-Systeme, Verringerung der Laufzeit bla, bla, bla, bla,
bla, bla, bla, und sieben Tagen auf 45 Minuten. Gewinner-Idee, Innovations-bla, bla, bla, bla,
bla, bla, bla, bla, okay, das kann ich jetzt nicht vorlesen. Und jetzt kommt der eigentliche
Zeugnisanteil. So, jetzt kommt der eigentliche Zeugnisanteil. Herr Max verfügt über ein
hervorragendes lasst euch das mal auf der zunge zergehen
herr marx verfügt über ein invasions champ wer invasiert hier also auf geht's
herr marx verfügt über ein hervorragendes und auch in randbereichen
sehr tiefgehendes fachwissen welches er in unserer welches er in unserer
unternehmen stets in höchst gewinnbringender weise einbringt
komischer satz aber ist glaube ich nicht schlecht er bildet sich stets in eigener
initiative durch den besuch interner externer seminare beruflich weiter und
ist dabei immer sehr erfolgreich aufgrund seiner aufgrund seiner
ausgezeichneten auffassungsgabe ist er jederzeit in der lage auch schwierige
situation sofort zutreffen zu erfassend und schnell exzellente
lösungen zu liefern zu finden zu finden zu finden herr marx zeigt fortwährend
hohe eigeninitiative und identifiziert sich absolut vortrefflich mit seinen
aufgaben und unserem unternehmen
aha wobei er auch durch seine vorbildliche einsatzfreude überzeugt
auch in situationen mit größtem arbeitsaufkommen erweist er sich
dauerhaft als außergewöhnlich belastbar alle aufgaben führt er jederzeit
vollkommen selbstständig äußerst sorgfältig und planvoll durchdacht aus er
agiert immer ruhig überzeugt er agiert immer ruhig überlegt zielorientiert
und in höchstem maße präzise dabei überzeugt er stets in besonderer weise
sowohl in qualitativer als auch in quantitativer hinsicht
herr marx ist in ganz besonderem hohem maße zuverlässig auch für es ist
gleich fertig leute wir haben es gleich geschafft das ist ein halber roman
auch für schwierigste problemstellungen findet er sehr
effektive lösungen der jederzeit erfolgreich in die praxis umsetzt und
damit immer ausgezeichnete arbeitsergebnisse erzielt
herr max erfüllt die ihm übertragenen aufgaben stets zu unserer vollsten
zufriedenheit er wird wegen seines konstant freundlichen und ausgeglichenen
wesens aller sei allerseits sehr geschätzt er ist immer hilfsbereit zu
vorkommen und stellt falls erforderlich auch persönliche interessen zurück sein
verhalten zu vorgesetzen zu vorgesetzten kolleginnen und kollegen sowie
kundinnen und kunden ist ausnahmslos und vorbildlich loyal und lojal
ok grund für die ausstellung dieses zwischenzeugnisses ist der wechsel von
herr max in den bereich bla bla bla bla bla wir bedanken uns bei ihm für die
bisherigen arbeitsverhältnisse erbrachten stets sehr gute leistungen
wünschen wir auch für neue aufgaben weiterhin alles gute so
das war mein zeugnis habt das gehört als könntet als könntet ihr das
irgendwie einordnen ihr könnt das genauso wenig einordnen wie ich für mich
klingt es gut aber zeugnisse klingen immer gut
ja gut jetzt habt ihr mein zeugnis gehört
chat kann alles gut chat kann alles gut wissen wir ja chat ist immer absolut
big brain high IQ es gibt nix es gibt nix was der chat nicht kann
wäre mal interessant was ein personal dazu sagen würde ja das wird mich auch
interessieren darfst nichts negatives in zeugnissen
sagen ja ja jetzt wisst ihr Bescheid
ok also wir fragen jetzt mal ob ein chat moment kann geht ihr auch auf deutsch
oh wir können es nicht ausprobieren oh shit shit leute es ist daun es ist daun ok mann einfach kündigung
arbeitsvertrag vorlage arbeitsvertrag musterkündigung für arbeitnehmer auf geht's der
afa anwalt der sagt sagt mir das geht ja sehr geehrte frau schmidt hiermit kündige ich das mit
ihnen bestehende arbeitsfeld ist ordentlich und fristgerecht zum nix möglichen zeitpunkt das ist
das klingt doch gut das klingt doch das das klingt doch gut hier sowas hier ja das ist doch gut das
ist doch das ist doch nice dass das doch top das nehmen wir einfach jetzt easy und ne muss ich das
jetzt wirklich in libre office machen oder muss ich das wirklich der textverarbeitung machen kann
man das nicht mit markdown irgendwie machen ist mal mein markdown ich habe kein bock office zu
verwenden und ks ach komm komm komm scheiß drauf was habe ich jetzt geöffnet base gehe weg das ist
das exes von den komm komm weil es hat das dark theme was ist das überhaupt für eine check for updates es
hat top aktuelle version die ich hier installiert habe das neue hat dark mode ok ok ach komm egal
egal wir schreiben es jetzt hier also zack was das geht ich hasse textverarbeitung leute ich hasse
textverarbeitung glaublich ok also kündigung des arbeitsverhältnisses sehr geehrte sehr geehrte
damen und herr ich schreibt jetzt da nicht nicht irgendwas hier ok hiermit künde ich das mit
ihnen bestehende arbeitsfeld ordentlichen fristgerecht zum nix möglichen dies ist nach
meinen berechnungen der kommt da der letzte arbeitstag rein oder der zeitpunkt an dem ich
kündigen kann also wahrscheinlich
der letzte arbeitstag seid ihr euch da sicher
da muss eigentlich datum rein hier oder wo habe ich das jetzt her
und zum nix möglichen zeitpunkt ja 31 12 da gibt es ja hat er 31 hat er überhaupt 31 tage
wie kurz ist meine kündigungsfrist also ich kann kündigen zum ende des quartals und dann
drei monate das dann ist es dann ist es vorbei die kündigung gebe ich aber jetzt schon die gebe
ich aber jetzt schon also ist wahrscheinlich dann ich muss mir mal andere vorlagen angucken
wichtig hier aber sind vertraglich einmal in fristen oder mindestlaufzeiten also muss
dann da wahrscheinlich wirklich der 31 dritte 2023 hin also quasi ab dann wenn ich wirklich
weg bin hiermit kündige ich das mit ihnen bestehend vom vom was weiß ich
das aufhebungsdatum ist schriftlich dass das also das ist ja im prinzip ich bitte sie mir
ein qualifiziertes berufsförderndes arbeitzeugnis auszustellen ja warum nicht sollte noch mal eins
schreiben warum ist das hier so ein komischer kackling was soll das
ok aber noch ein paar andere sachen mal gucken die karriere bibel was sagt die karriere bibel
also arbeit noch bis ende märz korrekt karriere bibel also das finde ich das finde ich besser
von der formulierung her das das finde ich das finde ich nicer von der formulierung her
wie ich textverarbeitung hasse man hiermit kündig ordentlich fristgerecht meinen arbeitsvertrag
zum nächsten möglichen zeitpunkt dieser meinbereich unter allen erkündigungsfrist
ja ein dritte 2023 als überhaupt 31 dritten gibt ja ok was haben die hier sonst noch stehen
bitte schicken sie mir das zusammen mit meiner na das ist so schon ok so das reicht scheiß
drauf das reicht macht doch kein latex dafür das reicht fertig aus easy da oben kommt jetzt
noch da oben kommt jetzt noch adresse adresse what the fuck ist jetzt passiert adresse adresse
adresse adresse kommt da oben noch hin dann kommt noch hin ja achter zwölfter 2022 irgendwie
sowas uns unterschrieben ja adresse das war ich jetzt nicht im stream so und irgendwie
und auch mal dann irgendwie datum unten drunter so und was ich jetzt gerne hätte ist noch
sowas kann man da ich würde gerne auch sowas drunter machen irgendwie wie er erhalten haben
oder sowas würde gerne das einfach zweimal ausdrucken und sie unterschreiben wir unterschreiben
wir das dann einfach ich bin am freitag in frankfurt da könnte ich es einfach vorbei
bringen ich will aber dass sie auf jeden fall bestätigen dass diese halten haben
drückt das zweimal aus und dann einfach einschreiben plus rückschein ich hab das selbst ab
alternativ kann ich mir das mit dem erhalten eigentlich auch sparen warum warum
ich bin am freitag jeder ja will ich will ich die kriege ich die kriege ich nicht unbedingt
steht drin dass sie mir das bestätigen sollen wenn sie einfach sagen sie haben sie gekriegt
deswegen sollen die misser unterschreiben dann kann gibt es da kein raus gerede mehr
ich druck das zweimal aus ich druck das zweimal aus und die sollen mir einfach unterschreiben
ich druck das zweimal aus und die sollen mir unterschreiben dass es dass es bekommen
haben fertig so in der richtung ich glaube das reicht schon was ich hier habe das keine
api verkündigung bestimmt bestimmt ja das mache ich so ich druck das einfach
das reicht ich glaube es ist genug mehr muss ich mehr muss ich da denke ich nicht machen
das passt es passt kündigung schreiben fitness studio alter ist das comic sans ist das comic
sans wirklich damit wird bestimmt nicht mal kündigung schreiben ok ich glaube das reicht
gespa danke schön für den sub ich glaube das passt so ich lasse ich lasse es jetzt
einfach so adresse und so fülle ich noch aus aber ohne euch das ist gut so das lassen
wir so fertig aus genug kündigung ist raus wenn du es dir direkt gibst brauchst du keine
bestätigung doch weil die immer noch sagen können sie haben sich erhalten oder ich muss
ein zeuge mitnehmen oder so dann lasse ich mir noch nie mehr bestätigen ich mache ein
video drüber ich filme mich ich mache einfach ein selfie ich nehme eine gopro mit und film
ich bei der abgabe das ist mal 2022 so muss man es machen livestream hast du einen neuen
arbeitgeber also streng genommen nein weil ich habe noch nicht unterschrieben aber ich
habe den vertrag schon so gut wie da welche branche ist der neue sage ich nicht aber es
ist keine bank so viel kann ich sagen also zumindest von denen wo ich den vertrag bekommen
habe und es auch kein porn anbieter und die bahnen ist es auch nicht zur bahn gehe ich
freiwillig nicht das kannst du vergessen
ja kann man so sagen ja doch das trifft ganz gut ja ja vor allem wegen den leuten mit
denen ich mich gut verstanden habe die firma an sich juckt mich nicht also es gibt viele
sachen die mir auf den keks gehen das mit homeoffice war jetzt halt so dem das i tüpfelchen
überall sachen die dir auf den keks gehen ja aber ich finde es ein bisschen blöd für
die leute mit denen ich mich gut verstanden hat mit denen ich mich gut verstanden habe
manchmal red ich zu schnell bevor ich mir die wörter überlegt habe die ich sagen will
bundeswehr nein ich gehe nicht zur bundeswehr danke für den sub zwei monate schon die abo
falle am start exzellent ist bei dir dass es die firma trifft dass du gehst keine ahnung
wahrscheinlich ja aber die leute die sowas entscheiden werden es gar nicht merken weil
es wieder meine ehemaligen teamkollegen ausbaden müssen weil die sich jetzt um den ganzen
mist mit kümmern müssen aber ich bin auch noch drei monate da also ich kann es ja jedem
neuen erklären was er machen muss wobei er das im endeffekt machen kann ist er da ist
bist du weg mal gucken ist mir auch egal die firma hat sich keinen meter bewegt ja ich
habe das wie gesagt ich habe also da kann sich wirklich keiner beschweren ja ich habe
das rechtzeitig meinem chef gesagt dass so wie das homeoffice technisch aktuell läuft
gerade nach den super ergebnissen jetzt in den letzten zwei jahren dass ich dass ich
das nicht auf dauer machen werde habe ich mehrfach gesagt habe ich ihm auch gesagt
ich suche mir gerade was anderes dann habe ich ihm gesagt ich habe jetzt was anderes
und nie hat sich die firma großartig bewegt oder denke ich mir auch leute ich kann euch
nicht zwingen dazu aber ihr mich auch nicht also ich bin mir sogar sehr sicher dass viele
sachen die ich jetzt gemacht habe wenn ich weg bin niemand weiter macht sei es unsere
technische technische dokumentation was server und konflikt angeht die wird einfach wenn
ich nicht mehr da bin auf exakt diesem stand bleiben und dann im halben jahr veraltet es
sein da bin ich mir relativ sicher und auch mal eine ganze selbst entwickelten tools und
software die ich dort am start hat mittlerweile wird auch keiner weiterentwickeln die benutzen
das solange es geht sobald was nicht mehr geht haben sie keine ahnung mehr davon
was ist das problem wir hatten jetzt während corona ich habe es ja schon oft genug erzählt
deswegen jetzt mal die kurzfassung während während corona also wir hatten davor schon
öfters mal home office aber seit corona hatten wir halt im großen stil home office und es
hat super es hat wirklich wunderbar funktioniert es hat besser funktioniert als vorher aus
meiner sicht und mir konnte bisher auch noch nie einer wirklich das gegenteil sagen ja
gehen wir plus alle recht immer dazu kommt dass ich gemerkt habe was für vorteile das
eigentlich hat ja ich wusste gar nicht wie müde ich bin und wie wenig man mit mir anfangen
kann und wie viel probleme ich auch hatte durch das frühe aufstehen und durch das hin und
hin und her pendeln und durch das viele fressen in frankfurt alles also mir geht es besser
ich schaffe mir also ist für mich besser gesundheitlich besser psychisch besser und für die firma
besser weil die kriegen mehr für ihr geld und ich schaffe mehr arbeit also ist für alle
beteiligten besser und mir hat das bisher auch nur jeder bestätigt und dann immer mit dem
zusatz so nach dem motto ja aber geht trotzdem nicht so und zumindest jetzt haben sie sich
ja überlegt ja es sollen alle wieder 50 prozent zurück ins büro und das habe ich von Anfang
an gesagt dass ich das nicht mal machen werde ich habe kein schmerz mit bei wichtigen sachen
dahin zu fahren auch mehrfach die woche ich habe auch keine schmerzen mit einmal die woche
zur abstimmung und zu wichtig vor ort zu sein aber den rest will ich home office machen
es ist für alle beteiligten besser ich arbeite mehr und habe bessere ergebnisse ich muss
mir den scheiß mit der bar nicht geben dementsprechend bin ich deutlich deutlich netter drauf auch
es ist für alle besser und deswegen habe ich mir jetzt gedacht gut geht halt nicht wenn
die sich nicht bewegen dann pech hat schon zeit den link im stream zu zeigen ach ja gut
dass du es bescheid sagst ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben leute es hat im discord das können wir jetzt
an der stelle mal kurz machen es hat im discord jemand gefragt ob wir seine patrick vielleicht
weißt du was ist bachelorarbeit oder sowas unterstützen können ob er eine umfrage ob
wir bei einer umfrage teilnehmen können das heißt wenn ihr so nett sein wenn ihr so nett
seid und den zu unterstützen wir gucken uns jetzt mal zusammen zusammen an im stream ich
habe jetzt ich habe jetzt leider den screenshot nicht hier sonst könnte ich nachgucken und
du brauchst ja dass so eine umfrage eben auch gewertet wird in der arbeit dass das irgendwie
repräsentativ oder was auch immer ist brauchst ja gewisse mindestanzahl an leuten die mit
gemacht haben und wir helfen ihm einfach mal bei seiner bachelorarbeit ich könnte jetzt
besser werbung für machen hätte ich mir mal screenshot von gemacht was eigentlich genau
seine bachelorarbeit ist genau hier hat er geschrieben also er ist derzeit am arbeiten
an seiner bachelorarbeit und er braucht ein paar personen die einen die ein fragebogen
zu dynamischer preissetzung mitmachen und zwar unter daraus resultierenden fairness wahrnehmung
der preise wäre es möglich dass ich den link zum fragebogen auf dem discord allgemein channel
post und vielleicht sogar ping auf also wir wollten keinen ping wir wollten keinen ping
auf dem discord machen deswegen habe ich gar nicht zeige euch das mal im stream das sieht
nach bvl aus ja er kann mich damit belästigen ich will ich jeden ich will nicht jeden stream
eine umfrage machen aber ab und zu ich meine es geht um die zukunft der leute da können
wir die mal unterstützen ich frage mich hier wir machen das jetzt einfach mal auf also
was will er dann hier liebe teilnehmerinnen liebe teilnehmer es freut mich sehr moment
wo ist wo ist dark mode sekunde das kann ich mir so nicht angucken ah ja excellent also
der michael ney märz und dem ist die umfrage von der leopold franzensuniversität in innsbruck
also es freut mich sehr dass sie die zeit nehmen und an einer wissenschaftlichen befragung
teilnehmen diese stunde führe ich im zugebeider bachelorarbeit an der universitäts innsbruck
und der um mit was zum ich weiß nicht was nur um ist aber ok in hall durch im folgenden
fragebogen werden fragen zu preisen von gütern welche miteinander im vergleich stehen gestellt
dabei gibt es keine richtige oder falsche antwort es wird lediglich versucht ihr befinden
als potenzielle konsumenten herauszufinden alles klar also leute ich poste das mal wer
bock hat das auszufüllen es hilft einem bei seiner bachelorarbeit ich finde es kann man
machen ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht ob ich das im stream machen soll weil verfälscht
das nicht die umfrage wenn ich im stream zeige was ich anklicke
ne aber leute ich werde es auch machen und wer ihm helfen will wäre nett wenn ihr euch
da die fünf minuten nehmt auch wenn es bvl ist und wir bwl eigentlich nicht mögen aber
sind wir mal so nett ok komm wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal ein video oder oder zwei an
die kündigt haben wir schon ist using cc cleaner a bad idea ich würde ganz ehrlich
sagen weder ja noch nein also ist meine einschätzung der sache weder ja noch nein oder eher ja
eher ja weil es bringt nicht wirklich was und im ernst im zweifelsfall macht irgendwas
kaputt und also wahrscheinlich wird es den 99 prozent der fällen nichts bringen also
ich würde ich würde prinzipiell bei mir kein cc cleaner installieren ganze tuning tools
halte ich für komplett useless müll
das ist das was ich auch schon seit jahren in
den videos sage es ist vollkommen egal ob die registry groß oder klein ist und da wurde
ich schon so oft in videos von irgendwelchen low iq leuten angegangen haben so nach dem
motto nein nein max du hast keine ahnung von du sprichst registry aufräumen registry
liegen ist ganz furchtbar wichtig ja aber ich sag es euch wie es ist es ist scheiß egal
wie fett die registry ist
das ist ja fast so viel wie ist ist odd und ist even das npm package
oder oder hat nur 500 hat nur 450.000 weekly downloads ich meine man kann in java script
ja auch nicht out of the box checken ob eine zahl gerade oder ungerade ist
best sellout bei denen immer
ich meine sponsoring in einem vier minuten 30 video
und ich war noch nie in einer wüste
das ist schonmal sehr sass was haben die geantwortet
wie kann das gehackt werden haben die den update server geknackt und dort
irgendeine drojaner verseuchte version aus ausgeliefert oder was oder wie soll das sonst
funktionieren
ja gut dass ich diesen müll nicht installiert habe
das braucht doch niemand
naja
man weiß von keinen issues die sie aktuell haben aber ich hätte es mir vorher nicht
installiert und jetzt würde ich es auch nicht installieren
ganz davon abgesehen ab und zu mal den browser cache leeren wenn man das aus irgendwelchen
gründen will ganz ehrlich eigentlich muss man den browser cache nie leeren oder nicht
wirklich also gibt eigentlich keinen keinen grund wirklich dafür warum man das machen
muss außer der speicherplatz wird super knapp und mal was deinstallieren kann auch so jeder
wirklich brauchen tut man es nicht
ich brauche überhaupt keine cleaning tools egal von wem sie sind
wir machen überhaupt nichts
also im prinzip ist es genauso wie ich mir das gedacht habe eigentlich kann man diese
ganzen tools knicken
ok in diese ganzen tools kann ich jetzt nicht sagen dieses tool knicken
ich hatte also ich habe sowas noch nie installiert ich werde sowas auch nicht installieren
der sinn der sinn hat sich mir noch nie erschlossen ich habe ja auch schon videos drüber gemacht
und wie gesagt leute haben damals gesagt doch doch registry ganz schlimm und das das macht
windows so langsam und das das hält sich ja bis heute noch hartnäckig dass die registry
windows langsam macht warum eigentlich
also warum macht die registry windows langsam aber irgendwelche großen json dateien wo
configs rausgelesen werden nicht
also die logik dahinter muss man mal einer erklären
womit kann man gut und sicher eine festplatte reinigen
entweder damit oder ehrlich gesagt was musst du großartig reinigen
du kannst unbenutzte dateien löschen ja
du kannst programme deinstallieren die du nicht mehr brauchst
du kannst alte downloads löschen ok aber was willst du da groß reinigen
es ist ja nicht so als entsteht durch das pure
angeschaltet sein irgendwie müll der nur auf magische art und weise entfernt werden
kann
übrigens auch ein weiterer grund warum es sehr sinnvoll ist
die festplatte zum beispiel standardmäßig zu verschlüsseln
wenn ihr nämlich mal kaputt geht dann könnt ihr sie nicht sicher wippen
müsst ihr aber auch nicht wenn sie verschlüsselt war weil eh niemand mit den daten was anfangen
kann die drauf sind
wie nur am besten die festplatte löscht einfach mit nullen überschreiben und fertig
einfach mit nullen überschreiben
ja normalerweise würde ich jetzt sagen dd aber du bist unter windows unter windows keine
ahnung
unter linux mache ich einfach ne dd def 0 nicht def random
wobei es egal ist also kannst du random nimm es aber langsamer
überschreibe einfach das komplette device block size 4 kilobyte und gibbi
es gibt tests dass es egal ist also kannst die festplatte mit nullen überschreiben
oder auch meinetwegen mit einsen überschreiben das reicht die ist heute so dicht und
ja so
es warnt die festplatten dass wenn du die einmal überschreibst du nichts mehr gescheit
restoren kannst
wenn natürlich ganz nun mal sicher gehen willst also sich sicherer als tests das für
nötig befunden haben kannst du sie mit random werten überschreiben und im zweifelsfall auch
mehrfach aber braucht man eigentlich gar nicht
bank da ich habe daten von betrüger gekauft
ist es der der letztens auch zum overwatch pro geworden ist
nee das war ein anderer das war tomali oder so
ich verwechsel die zwei irgendwie immer
was ist das für eine nice extension
ffz ja ffz da hast du auch noch mehr
tomatoli ja den mein ich den mein ich ja den den den
bin ich hier beste beste twitch extension
ok was haben wir sonst noch
ok das müssen wir jetzt nicht gucken
weil ich hab mein mainboard ja schon hier liegen
chat blöde frage
aber warum zeigt mein youtube denn bitteschön keine kann ich mich so hinsetzen aber dann
will ich
warum zeigt mein youtube denn keine kapitel an
kann ich mich so hinsetzen
einer du kannst hier hier zeigt kapitel an
jetzt sagt es keine kapitel an
ok
keine ahnung
oh nee was ist das für ein video das gucken wir nicht das gucken wir nicht leute ja guckt
euch die dislikes an alter level cap der hat jede
woche das gleiche dumme video alda langsam habe ich echt kein bock mehr drauf
jede woche der gleiche gleiche kram seit release von diesem game man
können sie neues fire ship video angucken das ist weird champ wird in 2023 55 minuten
minecraft jetzt kann ich mich nicht angucken
wir gucken uns wir gucken uns fire ship an fire ship fire ship macht meistens pogu videos
the best way to predict the future is to invent it i love this quote because
das ist das ist ein nicest quote das das gefällt mir
the best way to predict the future is to invent it
das ist das ist ein cooles zitat ja der beste weg die zukunft voraus zu sagen ist sie zu
erfinden
das ist feifett das ist das ist nice das finde ich cool nicht nicht dass man das jetzt irgendwie
einen persönlich weiter bringt aber das kann man immer zum klugscheißen verwenden
das finde ich gut
because as developers we have the incredible privilege of building the future for humanity
but based on the way things went in 2022 i think we must have done something wrong because
2022 has been a messed up year and there's probably more pain to come first russia and
ukraine went to war then all the high flying tech stocks declined in like 90 percent bitcoin
dropped from 69 to 16k while simultaneously gas and food doubled in price zuckerberg zuckerberg
the metaverse
ich habe heute gänsebraten gefuddert im restaurant 25 euro 90 pro person
pepo fett aber pepo massig teuer das mache ich auch nur einmal im jahr
geht der spruch im original nicht so keine ahnung
while elon destroyed free speech by allowing people to speak freely but most shocking of
all i found out my 100 percent natty fitness coach
das ist schon kurz davor auf twitter gecancelt zu werden
the liver king is actually juiced to the gills yes i'm on steroids apparently nothing is
what it seems in today's video we'll look at 10 trends affecting software development
and technology that you can capitalize on in 20 let's kick things off by talking about
tech jobs all the big tech corporations have either slowdowns hiring freezes or mass layoffs
if you're learning to code or looking for a job these headlines can be pretty scary
now while the job market for software engineers has definitely softened there's a few things
to keep in mind here first when there's massive layoffs like this the vast majority of jobs
have nothing to do with software engineering engineers are still extremely valuable and
most of those that were laid off were able to quickly find employment elsewhere second
outside of fang the job market still seems to be pretty strong it's by no means frozen
up and there are still tons of job openings out there especially at non-tech companies
that have struggled to modernize the bad news is that interest rates are still high and
will likely remain high at least until 2024 that means less easy money for startups to
over hire there's still a labor shortage in tech and if that ever changes look out below
because that's the greater that's what we're changing this is why i'm not going to believe
that this is really changing so to speak the lack of expertise
this is nintendo weihnachtsmusik or das bonkers alda excellent entspannend ich meine es ist
immerhin bald weihnachten dass ich jetzt mal kurz mittag grundudeln ja was wollte ich denn
jetzt sagen genau wisst ihr warum ich nicht davon ausgehe dass ich das mit dem fachkräftemangel
überhaupt mal legen wird im it sektor zwar ist das der folgende grund es kann nicht jeder
it experte werden ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal it experte ja egal in welchem bereich
und was genau es kann nicht jeder it experte werden es ist nicht so dass du jetzt einfach
irgendjemand nehmen könntest der früher im bergbau war und dem eine umschulung zum fisi
verpasst und er ist auf einmal super high IQ informatiker das funktioniert in einzelnen
fällen aber nicht in der masse du hast dort sicherlich leute die das ohne probleme könnten
aber nicht die masse also du hast bestimmt den ein oder anderen den du umschulen kannst
aus den berufen die man jetzt nicht mehr braucht aber bestimmt nicht die masse und aus dem
grund ist es nicht so dass in den anderen bereichen welche aufhören und man die irgendwie
massenweise dann fisi umschulung verpassen kann ich weil man kann den leuten schon eine
fisi umschulung verpassen die braucht danach aber trotzdem keiner wenn sie keine ahnung
haben es ist übrigens ja tatsächlich so wie der chatter das ist in jedem beruf so es
kann nicht jeder alles und das muss einem auch klar sein also es liegt nicht jedem alles
warum auch immer das so ist ja gibt leute sind zu blöd die haben gar keinen bock alles
mögliche in alle richtungen ich könnte zum beispiel keine sozialen berufe machen weil
ich erstens menschen hasse und zweitens interaktion mit anderen menschen noch mehr außer es ist
natürlich mein twitch chat dann sieht das ganze anders aus also ich könnte das nicht
machen ich könnte weder im kindergarten arbeiten noch im in der pflege noch irgendwo irgendwo
anders das ist ein steig ich meine das so ich mag andere menschen absolut gar nicht
alter wenn ich die wenn ich die auswahl habe andere menschen oder keine anderen menschen
dann entscheide ich mich immer für keine anderen menschen ich bin das was man so allgemein
den menschenhasser nennt ich kann überhaupt keiner ich mag standardmäßig erstmal leute
nicht bis auf die ganz seltenen ausnahmen wo ich dann mal jemand mag und dafür wenn
ich jemand mag dann ist nice ja aber die meisten mag ich nicht was eventuell auf gegenseite
beruht was mich aber nicht weiter interessiert aber die meisten leute interessieren mich
nicht mag ich will ich mir den nix zu tun haben die meisten leute geben mir ehrlich
sagen am arsch vorbei also ich bin keiner der gerne social isen will und jetzt habe
ich vergessen was ich sagen wollte darum soll es jetzt eigentlich gar nicht gehen ja fachkräftemangel
also wie gesagt ich könnte auch ich könnte auch solche sozialen sachen nicht machen und
dementsprechend kann auch nicht jeder fisi oder was in diese richtung lernen das funktioniert
nicht
also wie gesagt das wird nicht funktionieren ich wollte noch irgendwas sagen aber ich habs
komplett durch meinen exkurs jetzt zu ich mag andere menschen nicht vergessen
aktuell ist das mit der umfrage ja ich hoffe ich hoffe es haben ein paar mitgemacht wie
viele haben wir dann aktuell wie viele brauchen wir noch für die umfrage wie viel brauchen
wir noch für die umfrage umfrage wo link hier leute ja genau mir fällt es leider nicht
mal ein ich wollte irgendwas dazu sagen zu der ganzen fachkräftemangelgeschichte also
wie gesagt das ist halt das nicht funktioniert das kann ich hier alles machen und es werden
eher noch mehr gebraucht werden in der zukunft gerade auch in bereichen wo jetzt jobs wegfallen
ich meine es muss ja nicht bergbau sein ja es könnte auch irgendwo am fließband oder
sonst was sein klar es entstehen neue arbeitsplätze aber halt nicht die diesmal gegeben hat also
du wirst keine bergbauer mehr brauchen du wirst wahrscheinlich auch weniger fließbandarbeiter
und sowas brauchen aber du brauchst trotzdem leute die sich mit maschinen auskennen die
sachen programmieren können die sich mit art auskennen auskennen das wird zwar nicht
in diesem maße an neuen leuten gebraucht wie die alten vielleicht wegfallen in diesen
branchen aber es wird auf jeden fall neue geben und du kannst nicht die alten leute
da irgendwie hin umschulen zum größten teil deswegen glaube ich dass ich das fachkräfte
technisch nie wirklich entspannen wird so dass jeder wieder so wie es ihnen vorschwebt
dass jeder für den apple und ein ei nichts bezahlen muss sich nicht anstrengen muss und
irgendwelche it experten bekommt das wird es nicht geben da bin ich war ich relativ
sicher dass ich das auch in den nächsten zehn jahren ich irgendwie legen wird wenn
die sich natürlich mühe geben versuchen die leute geziel anzusprechen ordentliches gehalt
bieten ordentlichen arbeitsplatz bieten ordentliche bedingungen bieten dann sieht das wieder
anders aus ist ja nicht wirklich so als hätten wir gar keine leute wir haben halt bloß nicht
für jede offene stelle die sich irgendwo irgend einer ausgedacht hat der dafür nichts
machen will und nichts bezahlen will und keine vorzüge bietet jemand der quasi es machen muss
weil er sonst verhungert um es übertrieben zu sagen das haben wir nicht aber wenn man welche
will bekommt man auch welche ja und deswegen glaube ich dass ich das fachkräfte mangel
technisch nie entspannen wird was für uns gut ist also nie so dass es wieder so ist dass jeder
für den apple und ein kriegt und 20 haben es gemacht na komm leute klickt ihr mal die umfrage
durch leute von paar jahren hat das besser funktioniert das weiß ich noch da hat mich
mal jemand hat mich den medel mal gefragt ob ich ihre umfrage zeigen kann und da habe ich
das in dem video gezeigt und das war dann der buber bonus wahrscheinlich haben die leute
irgendwie instant 500 leute mitgemacht alles fehlen noch 20 ach so ja das kriegen wir easy noch
hin
das wird zeit bitte ja die umfrage schließt in zwei minuten du musst schnell fertig werden
du hast wahrscheinlich noch drei wochen dafür zeit lasst euch zeit lasst lasst euch zeit
freut sich über jeden der mitmacht auch wenn es erst morgen ist der hype trainiert sich
monke ist die bahn kommt leute herkli danke für den sub ok kommen wir das video weiter gibt es
viele ältere IT fachkräfte ja also natürlich jetzt nicht wie in anderen berufen so extrem ja
aber klar gibt es auch ich habe mir dürfen nicht vergessen IT fachkräfte gibt es ja seit
den 1970 ist jetzt übertrieben da war das jetzt alles noch weniger aber sagen wir mal so seit
1980 hat es zugenommen es mögen jetzt vielleicht damals nicht die jobs gewesen sein wie sie heute
sind aber sind auch IT fachkräfte also ich würde sagen so ab 1980 und spätestens 90er und 2000er
hat es natürlich extrem zugenommen und davon sind die leute heute auch 50 plus guck mal mich an
guck mal mich an ich bin 1984 geboren das heißt ich bin jetzt 38 ewig mache ich das auch nicht
mehr richtig richtig boomer ewig mache ich das auch nicht mehr also ich kann euch eins sicher sagen
ich weiß gar nicht wo das rentenalter aktuell ist 67 oder ob es schon 70 ist keine ahnung ich
kann euch nur eins sagen ich werde im leben nichts bis 67 arbeiten gehen 67 und wir haben
schon gedacht du studierst pwl wegen der umfrage hättest du gleich gesagt dass du software digital
digital business ins studierst hätten die leute mehr mitgemacht weil wir mögen ja keine bw la
aber jemand das software engineering digital business studiere das da kein problem
also wie gesagt ich werde im leben nicht bis 67 arbeiten das kann ich euch sagen also sicher
wie das arme in der kirche ich werde noch eine weile arbeiten vor allem dass so wie ich das mache
für mich auch die optimale kombi ist aus teilzeit und den rest youtube und sachen auf die ich bock
habe ach so es war doch bw l monka es hatten die leute doch recht dass sie skeptisch waren immer
sinnlose meetings und diskussionen ja ist so ich habe auch teilweise tage da miete ich sechs stunden
von sieben halb es ist nicht normal egal wir gucken jetzt erstmal hier fertig ich gehe noch
mal ganz kurz zurück vielleicht fällt mir dann wieder ein was ich ursprünglich sagen wollte das
stimmt wohl wobei ich da das ein bisschen anders sehe es gibt zwei es gibt da zwei welten
es gibt die die erkannt haben dass das für alle beteiligten das beste ist wenn man die leute
da arbeiten lässt wo sie wollen ich sage nicht dass es für alle beteiligten das beste ist sie
zum homeoffice zu verdonner sondern ich sage dass es es gibt unternehmen die haben es verstanden
dass es wahrscheinlich für alle beteiligten das beste ist die leute dort arbeiten zu lassen wo
sie wollen mit ein paar regularien natürlich und es gibt die die sich gefeiert haben in
corona zeiten dafür dass homeoffice möglich ist die aber ins geheim das eigentlich nie wollten
und das sind die die heute auch probleme machen und rum nerven von wegen unsere tolle bürokultur
und bla bla bla bla bla diese zwei sorten gibt es und das eine sind halt meistens relativ
alteingesessene boomer dominierte manager etagen und das andere irgendwelche leute dies gecheckt
haben dass gerade wenn man IT fachleute haben will auch gucken muss dass ein job attraktiv ist und
die leute haben sie in corona verstanden dass es für sie besser ist und auch für den arbeitgeber
by the way wenn sie sich nicht am tag eineinhalb stunden in den zug setzen und mit der abgefackten
bahn fahren müssen oder aber sich vor ort in irgendwelche sinnlos meeting räume einschließen
müssen vier stunden am tag das erste was gefragt wird das habe ich aus erster hand mehrfach gehört
sowohl von meinem jetzigen chef als auch von meinem letzten chef als auch von unserem abt
als von allen von allen das erste was gefragt wird ist wenn es beim wenn es um bewerbung geht
meistens schon bevor das bevorstellungsgespräch überhaupt stattfindet wird gefragt
mein mikrofon knackst wieder kurz ja das liegt daran weil ich ein boomer bin und die ganze zeit
hier guck mal an an mein hier hörst du es an mein pulli komme weil ich so schepp da sitze
eben hat man es wieder gehört ne ne das ist weil ich weil ich blöd bin und ans mikro gekommen
jetzt jetzt sollte da eigentlich nichts mehr sein klang anders vielleicht ist mein desktop
wieder zu voll wollen wir mal gucken ob es ob es wieder der test der test war ja relativ einfach
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla und jetzt seiten reloaden größere seiten reloaden im im
browser und da hat es dann dabei geruckelt jetzt hat es jetzt geruckelt und im im browser und da
hat es dann dabei geruckelt jetzt ist egal so also weiter geht es
ja genau also die zwei sortenunternehmen gibt es halt und das sind dann lustigerweise auch die die
sich dann keine leute finden für wie gesagt genau das war ich sag mal also ich habe es wie gesagt
mehrfach aus erster hand gehört das erste was gefragt wird ist wie sieht es mit homeoffice regelungen aus
und meistens wird das schon über den jeweiligen personalvermittler wenn man sich nicht selbst
bewirkt gefragt und sobald dann gesagt wird nie gibt bei uns nichts dann sind die leute weg also
ich habe es letztens wieder von meinem jetzigen chef gehört bewerber passt gut sie wollen
vorstellungsgespräch vereinbaren vereinbaren der bewerber fragt über seinen vermittler nach wie
sieht es mit homeoffice regelungen aus mein chef antwortet ja während korona zeiten haben wir was
ansonsten tja gibt es eigentlich nix und nie wieder was von ihm gehört da muss man sich nicht
wundern aber so pech was macht eigentlich nft aktuell so
viel
denn es gibt viele Schlammere und Kriminelle, die ausgedreht werden müssen.
Reden wir auch über den Metaverse.
Zuckerberg hat den Namen Facebook geändert und Billionen Dollar in dieses Projekt verpackt.
Ja, genau, und man hat einen schlecht aufgelösten Eiffeltower gesehen.
Eiffeltower, Alter, Eiffelturm.
Und es sieht halt einfach schlechter aus als fucking Second Life vor 15 Jahren.
Die Leute könnten auch ganz einfach VR Chat spielen, wenn sie sich mit einem Headset vor
den Rechner setzen wollen und mit anderen Leuten zusammen irgendwie abhängen.
Wenn überhaupt, dass sowas Mainstream Verbreitung finden sollte und dass die Leute das auch
noch den größten Teil des Tages verwenden, da muss es da irgendeine neue Erfindung geben.
Das ist ja quasi ein bisschen in die Richtung, wie man jetzt Smartphones hat.
War ja vorher auch undenkbar, dass die Leute quasi ihr halbes Leben da mit einem Smartphone
da verbringen.
Also zu Zeiten von fetten Nokia-Handys hat das keiner für möglich gehalten.
Also sowas in der Richtung muss da passieren, dass die Leute das halben Tag benutzen und
nicht einen fetten Display vor dem Kopf haben.
Ey, es gibt noch mehr Videos, nicht mehr Videos, Alter, Leute, manchmal, ich muss langsam
mal reden, Leute.
Ich rede immer schon, bevor ich überhaupt das Wort in meinem Kopf geformt habe zu dem,
was es werden soll.
Es gibt noch mehr Programme in der Richtung, es gibt da diese Chat-AI, ihr habt vorhin gesehen,
es gibt, man kann Videos generieren, man kann Kunstsachen generieren, es gibt Sachen, die
schreiben Gedichte und sowas, es gibt richtig abgedrehtes Zeug mittlerweile.
Ja, 3D Models, habe ich auch letztens gehört, ja, und was auch richtig krass ist, ja, das
zum Beispiel, was auch richtig krass ist, dass du dir irgendwelche Reden von Steve Jobs
oder Elon Musk oder so zusammenwursten kannst.
Letztens habe ich einen Fake gesehen, dass Elon Musk angeblich gesagt hat, das war offensichtlich
ein Fake, ja, hat gesagt, wenn Skill-Based Matchmaking nicht entfernt wird, dann kauft
er Activision und wirft alle raus, ja, war natürlich vorher auch schon offensichtlich,
dass es Fake ist, aber es war ein unglaublich guter Fake.
Du bist eine Erinnerung aus dem Vergangenen, gut zu sehen, Kumpel, es ist ein langer Zeitpunkt,
seit ich auf der Show war.
Und über die letzte Woche ist die Welt verrückt über Chat-GPT gegangen, was smart genug ist,
deine Algebra-Halte zu machen, die Poetry für deine Frau zu schreiben und deinen gebrochenen
Koden zu fixieren.
Stack Overflow hat sogar Schritte gemacht, um es zu bannern, weil die Leute es benutzen,
um Antworten zu schreiben, die sie nichts wissen.
Aber jetzt will ich einen 180 machen und über Frontend und Web Development reden.
legends, staatlichen Cours서, rotate myself.
When they found out, optical
play malt
was
ich
do
web
Opening
like
a
Alternativen heutzutage, die 0.js von default, besserer Leistung, neuer APIs und so weiter
bieten. Und es gibt neue JavaScript-Frameworks, die jede einzelne...
Wie jetzt? Hättet ihr damit gerechnet, dass es neue JavaScript-Frameworks gibt? Also ich
nicht. Ich dachte, nach 2022 erscheinen nie wieder ein neues JavaScript-Framework.
... heute, die Grenzen des Möglichen.
Wollen wir das machen? Wollen wir das machen?
Gucken, vielleicht haben wir noch Zeit.
Ja, na gut, die Alternative ist Webpack und Webpack ist Ultra-Paints-Champ.
Ach, stimmt. Written in Rust, blazingly fast, ich vergaß.
Es gab ja mal Zeiten, da sah jede Website, die sie verwendet hat, wie sie sie verwendet
hat.
Es gab ja mal Zeiten, da sah jede Website aus wie Bootstrap.
Sie war wahrscheinlich auch Bootstrap, aber die konnte sie gar nicht mehr auseinanderhalten.
Was? Neobrutalism? Alles klar. Wer denkt sich die Namen für diese Trends aus?
Ja, wenn man öffentliche Seiten und Services hat, aber nicht für zum Beispiel irgendein
internes Zeiterfassungssystem oder so, das wird bestimmt nicht auf der Edge gerendert
Server sein.
Soll ich euch erklären, was damit gemeint ist? Nur mal für den Fall der Fälle, dass
nicht alle so im Frontend-Game drin sind. Also was damit gemeint ist, ist folgendes
hier. Edge-Server-Side-Rendering. Also, wie erkläre ich das jetzt am besten? Der klassische
Ansatz von Web-Anwendung ist ja, wir lassen mal Single-Page-Applications außen vor.
Das macht jetzt in dem Fall keinen Sinn, das groß noch eins. Also der klassische Ansatz
von so einer Web-Anwendung ist ja, also zum Beispiel, wenn ich auf YouTube gehe. Nee,
YouTube ist ein doofes Beispiel. Wenn ich auf heise.de gehe, so, dann funktioniert das
folgendermaßen. Ich mache die Website auf, ich gehe zum Web-Server und dort läuft dann
irgendeine Web-Anwendung. Irgendein Blogging-System wahrscheinlich oder irgendein Content-Management-System
oder was auch immer. Der baut dann die Seite für mich schon zusammen und schickt mir quasi
das HTML zurück, was mein Browser dann anzeigt. Das ist das, wie Webseiten schon immer funktioniert
haben. Ich bekomme HTML geschickt und mein Browser zeigt die Seite an. Zwischenzeitlich
gab es den Trend hin, dass das nicht mehr so gewesen ist, sondern dass man sowas wie
Single-Page-Applications zum Beispiel gemacht hat, wo man dann einfach nur einen riesen
Haufen JavaScript geschickt bekommen hat und sich die Seite dann quasi klein-seitig
aufgebaut hat und über irgendwelche APs halt die Daten abgefragt hat und sie dann klein-seitig
gerendert hat. Also es wurde nicht das HTML auf dem Server erzeugt, an Browser geschickt
und der Browser zeigt es an, sondern es wurde JavaScript geschickt, das JavaScript tatsächlich
Daten abgerufen hat, dann das HTML im Browser klein-seitig gerendert. Deswegen, also das
sind Single-Page-Applications beziehungsweise klein-seitige Geschichten. Jetzt geht es aber
um Edge Server-Side Rendering. Server-Side Rendering ist das Klassischste der Klassischen,
was Web-Anwendungen angeht. Also sprich, der Server erzeugt HTML, was er an euch schickt
und euer Browser zeigt es an. Das hat den Vorteil, dass es relativ schnell ist, wenn
du die Seite öffnest, weil dein Browser muss ja nichts machen, außer das HTML anzeigen
und es ist gut für Suchmaschinen, weil Suchmaschinen sind ziemlich gut drin, HTML zu passen und
den Content zu indizieren. Hat natürlich ein paar Nachteile im Vergleich zu Single-Page-Applications,
besonders dynamische Inhalte, Sachen, die sich automatisch updaten und sowas, das geht
damit natürlich nicht. Da brauchst du wieder JavaScript und je nachdem, wie dynamisch und
wie ausgefeilt das sein soll, fährst du vielleicht mit einem großen Buzzen klein-seitigem JavaScript
besser. So und jetzt kommen wir zum Thema Edge Server-Side Rendering. Da versucht man
Folgendes. Stellt euch Server-Side Rendering, Klassisches Server-Side Rendering vor, also
sprich, der Server erzeugt HTML, das dann zu euch geschickt wird und euer Browser zeigt
an, nur dass es nicht mehr einen Server gibt, der das macht, sondern es gibt weltweit ganz
viele Server, die das machen. Und es wird derjenige genommen, der am nächsten an euch
dran ist, oder sagen wir mal einer, der recht nah an euch dran ist, der quasi on the edge
ist zu euch, also möglichst nah bei euch. Also sprich, wenn ihr eine Web-Anwendung aufmacht
von der Seite in den USA, dann ist es nicht mehr so, dass euer Request an den Server in
die USA geht, dort baut der Server das HTML zusammen, schickt es an euch zurück und euer
Browser zeigt es an, sondern, dass die Seite vielleicht gerendert wird in Frankfurt. Vielleicht
ist die Datenbank irgendwo in den USA oder zumindest der Master-Datenbank-Server in den
USA oder was auch immer, aber eure Webseite wird quasi ausgeliefert von einem Server in
Frankfurt oder dort erzeugt. Zwischenschritt ist, dass man es halt nur zwischenzeitlich
cached auf so einer Kiste, aber das ist das, was sich hinter Edge-Server-Seit-Rendering
verbirgt. Also du erzeugst das HTML für den Browser möglichst nah am Ort des Benutzers.
Warum man das macht, ist relativ simpel. Ladezeiten. Ladezeiten sind das wichtigste,
wenn du Geld mit Webseiten verdienen willst. Weil jeder, der von deiner Webseite verschwindet,
bevor du ihn mit deinem Content überzeugen konntest, ist verlorenes Geld. Und was meint
ihr, warum Amazon so viel Geld reinsteckt? Den Bestellprozess und solche Sachen bei
ihnen auf der Webseite zu analysieren. Weil jeder durch quasi, der durch Webseitenprobleme
abspringt, verlorenes Geld ist. Die wollen wissen, wenn die Leute es nicht checken, dass
sie auf den wahren Korb oben rechts klicken müssen. Die wollen wissen, wenn die Leute
es nicht checken, dass sie irgendwie auf sofort bezahlen klicken müssen. Und die wollen natürlich
auch nicht, dass die Leute abspringen, weil die Seite zu langsam lädt. Und das Problem
haben alle. Deswegen versucht man das möglich. Ist das nicht das gleiche wie CDN? Naja,
ähnlich. CDN ist das schon eine Weile so. Aber CDN, da geht es ja darum, um statische
Bilder auszuliefern oder JavaScript Libraries auszuliefern. Hier geht es ja darum, die Webseite
fix und fertig zusammenzubauen. Nicht einfach nur Bestandteile der Seite irgendwie zwischenszuspeichern
und möglichst nach auszuliefern, sondern die komplette Seite fertig gerendert an dich
auszuliefern. Das ist halt der Unterschied. Und alles nur, damit die Ladezeiten raufgehen,
weil Ladezeiten das wichtigste sind überhaupt. Was genau ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen
SSR und Edge SSR? SSR ist ganz klassisch das, wie Internet bzw. Webseiten schon immer funktioniert
haben. Nur, dass es jetzt möglichst nah an dir dran passiert. Wie gesagt, bei klassischem
Server-Site-Rendering, wenn ich eine Seite in den USA aufmache, wird mein Content bzw.
mein HTML, was mein Browser anzeigt, wird vom Server in den USA ausgeliefert. Wenn die
das mit Edge SSR machen, dann kommt es von einem Server in Frankfurt zum Beispiel. Das
hat natürlich weitere Herausforderungen. Die einfachste Variante ist natürlich immer
noch Server-Site-Rendering an einer Stelle und gut ist. Edge SSR hat natürlich noch
mehr Herausforderungen. Zum Beispiel, wo kriegst du deinen Content her? Also, wenn du Datenbank-Zugriffe
machen musst, zum Beispiel, es ist eine Webseite, wo, was weiß ich, ihr wollt eure Bestellhistorie
angucken, dann ist es natürlich schwierig, das auszuliefern, weil, naja, die Edge hat
ja vielleicht eure Daten nicht. Da hast du dann wiederum das Problem, ja, du musst vielleicht
eine Datenbank verteilt über die Welt haben. Da gibt es ja auch schon Services für und
dafür kannst du dann zum Beispiel solche Sachen wie, was er hier hat, Serverless-Edge-Computing
und so Zeug verwenden, aber es ist ja auch ein Trend, dass man Datenbanken verteilt versucht
anzubieten. Also, vielleicht einen Master hat, der schreiben kann einmal auf der Welt,
aber Read-Only-Instanzen beispielsweise auf jedem Kontinent eine oder so was, weil irgendwo
mussten die Daten ja herkommen. Also, das macht es nicht einfacher, das macht es komplizierter,
aber unterm Strich sorgt es dafür, dass man damit mehr Geld verdienen kann, weil die Seiten
bei deinen potenziellen Kunden schneller lädt. Es knackst, ok, zeig mal her. Was genau ist
jetzt der Unterschied zwischen SSR und Edge SSR? Oh, das hatten wir schon mal, das hatten
wir schon mal. Ich weiß nicht, was es war, Leute, aber das letzte Mal hat sich es von
alleine gefixt. Hoffen wir mal, dass es sich wieder alleine
gefixt. Es ist bestimmt OneDrive. Warum läuft denn der Shit hier auch? Alter OneDrive-Keckel.
Das ist die einfachste Variante davon. Die Sache ist bloß die, du kannst die Seite ja
nicht unbedingt zwischenspeichern, weil wie sollen die in Frankfurt die Seite zwischenspeichern,
wenn du deine Bestellhistorie angucken willst? Deine Bestellhistorie kann nicht zwischengespeichert
werden, weil niemand anderes macht deine Bestellhistorie auf. Die muss dort erzeugt werden, die Seite,
zumindest das erste Mal. Danach ist sie bestimmt gecashed. Und das passiert möglichst nah an
dir dran, dass deine Ladezeiten kurz sind und du möglichst schnell auf die Idee kommst,
ah, ich könnte dir noch was weiteres bestellen. Also das ist tatsächlich ein Trend dieses
Jahr gewesen, ja. SvelteKit. SvelteKit. Beste.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ihr bei der Oracle Cloud ne kostenlose VM erstellen könnt? Wer
auch immer Oracle Cloud verwendet.
Das hat er im Nachhinein reingezogen, das hat er im Nachhinein reingezogen, das hat er
im Nachhinein reingeschnitten, das hat er im Nachhinein reingeschnitten, das hat er im
Nachhinein reingeschnitten. Wahrscheinlich hat er ausversehen GRPC gesagt und hat sich
dann gedacht, fuck, ich hab mich versprochen.
SerialDB. SerialDB, habe ich da im Hinterkopf, die angeblich alles können sollen. Wollen,
wollen, wollen.
Das ist aber auch wichtig, ja, muss man noch mal sagen, also jetzt nicht unbedingt SerialDB,
aber so Sachen wie CassandraDB oder so zum Beispiel. Das passt natürlich wie die Faust
aufs Auge auf zu solchen Sachen wie Edge Server-side-rendering, weil wie gesagt, wenn
möglichst nah an dir dran die Webseite gerendert werden soll, braucht die natürlich auch die
Daten, und da ist eine verteilte Datenbank natürlich deutlich besser, als eine Datenbank,
die dann doch wieder am anderen Ende der Welt steht. CockroachDB. Yep, yep, CockroachDB.
Road to be. Aber wenn ich verwende, ich kenne bloß Cassandra DB, aber das ist auch so was in die Richtung.
Natürlich praktisch, wenn du dann die Datenbank verteilt über die gesamte Welt hast, dann kann die Edge eben auch schneller rendern.
Wie gesagt macht es alles ein bisschen komplexer und du hast im Zweifelsfall auch mehr Probleme dadurch, aber wenn du Sachen verkaufen willst im Internet
beziehungsweise Geld verdienen willst mit Web-Services und Sachen die du auf deiner Webseite hast, dann ist Ladezeiten eines der wichtigsten Sachen.
Es gibt auch viele populäre Database, wie Neo4j und MongoDB, die auch nun auch ohne Server haben. Ich werde jetzt ein Video machen, das all diese Database in der Zukunft vergleichen wird, also abonniere dich auf den Kanal.
Eine andere Sache, die wir auf der Rückseite reden müssen, ist die Idee, dass Menschen zutreffend von Sprachen wie C++, 2022 und Carbon ausgehen wollen, aber es ist Jahre her, von der Produktion bereit zu sein.
Die dominanten neue Systems-Language in 2023 ist russisch, vielleicht nicht in der totalen Adoption, aber definitiv in der Mind-Share neuer Entwickler. Nicht nur ist es lieb von Entwicklern,
Was mit Redis passiert ist, Redis gibt es immer noch und wird immer noch oft verwendet. Scheint nicht mehr so krasse Hype-Technologie zu sein, aber ist immer noch verbreitet.
Es gibt viele moderne Systeme, aber vor einigen Monaten wurde es offiziell an den Linux-Kernel genutzt. Das bedeutet, dass weitere Updates an den Linux-Kernel in Rust werden geschrieben werden können.
Ich verstehe, dass die meisten von uns hier zu dumm sind, sich immer noch an den Linux-Kernel zu konzentrieren, aber der Tatsache, dass Linus Torvalds Rust in das Ökosystem willkommen, sagt viel über die Zukunft der Sprache. Und das gibt uns 10 Trends, die zu beobachten sind.
Die Tatsache, dass ihr es so weit in die Video gemacht habt, bedeutet, dass ihr die Tatsache durchgeführt habt. Danke fürs Zuschauen und ich sehe euch in der nächsten.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir das in 10 Minuten hinkriegen.
Willkommen!
Wie sieht die Seite ohne Darkreader aus?
Ah, auch ganz gut.
Keg.js
Keg. Javascript
Language
Willkommen zu der Survey des...
... aber ich habe es noch nicht genutzt, das ist gut.
Proxys
Was meinen die mit Proxys in Verbindung?
Mit Javascript, die meinen doch bestimmt nicht sowas wie Squid.
Die meinen doch irgendwas anderes, oder?
Die meinen irgendwas in Javascript, was Proxys heißt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Proxy Objects
Keine Ahnung.
Promise all settled
Hab ich schon mal was von gehört?
Dynamic import
Hab ich auch schon mal was von gehört?
Das habe ich schon verwendet.
Das finde ich nice.
Private fields
Hab ich auch schon mal was von gehört, habe ich verwendet?
Numeric separators
Ah, das ist das, wenn man Punkte und so machen kann, dass man lange Zahlen besser erkennen kann.
Ja, habe ich wahrscheinlich sogar schon benutzt.
Replace all
Replace all?
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass das neu ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Logical assignments
Den dealing
DenBeuar
Also, als Somerset
Tralos
Er reside
Wie markets
Hä?
Ist das neu?
ich dachte so was so was ach so jaja moment doch doch das ist neu das wusste ich tatsächlich
nicht dass es in dieser form gibt promise any ja das kenne ich schon das bin ich mir nicht sicher
aber ich kenne es auf jeden fall top level a weight ja beste ist das die neue time api
temporal api ja kenne ich habe ich weiß noch nicht ob ich schon verwendet habe
ray find last kennen weiß ich habe ich noch nicht verwendet keine ahnung
mein try catch kenne ich aber prototype course dass man jetzt irgendwie keine ahnung
has own habe ich schon mal gehört rex match indices kein schimmer browser api apis ok ja
wir kommen da durch bis um bis um 10 kannst du was empfehlen um sich als sozusagen mit
programmiererfahrung dieses hippe frontend zeug beizubringen ja finde ich auf jeden fall gut
weil an frontend sachen kommt man früher oder später nicht vorbei und ich muss sagen ich komme
ja auch aus der linux admin welt ursprünglich mal auch dank meiner ausbildung beim internet
provider mir macht das spaß sogar mittlerweile frontend sachen zu basteln ich hätte es nie für
möglich gehalten das beste ist wahrscheinlich sich in framework rauszusuchen was schön ein was
einsteigerfreundlich ist und einfach was zu bauen irgendwas wenn du das glück hast kannst du interne
tools bauen für die arbeit und ansonsten irgendwas was du was du gerne gerne machen willst ich
persönlich mags welt recht gern wie es ist aber zum einstieg auch wunderbar wie es ist aber auf
jeden fall die also wie es ist glaube ich ist das von von leute wie es ist es nukst oder next
nukst ja also ich persönlich mags weltkit weltkit nähert sich auch version 1.0 dass es
da nicht mehr wöchentlich breaking changes gibt also ich mags weltkit ich mag view auch aber die
letzten sachen die wir auch im stream gebastelt haben generell die die ich gebastelt haben
waren eigentlich fast alle ins welt mit weltkit geht aber beides react würde ich erst mal mir
das gar nicht geben wenn du natürlich sowas beim job verwenden willst klar react ist halt nach wie
vor das breite das verbreitetste ich persönlich wird einen großen bogen angular machen das hat
mich so komplett abgeschreckt rein von der einsteiger freundlichkeit her muss ich sagen gefällt mir
welt und view am besten view hat halt ein bisschen den vorsprung paar jahre dass es ein bisschen
verbreiteter ist und bisschen mehr zu gibt aber weltkit hat gut aufgeholt das letzte jahr ich
persönlich finde es mittlerweile angenehmer ist aber geschmackssache geht beides kanns view
oder das welt verwenden beziehungsweise nukst oder weltkit und im endeffekt am java script
kennen wir es dir nicht vorbeikommen pures java script für webseiten ich weiß nicht dafür ist
es mir immer noch zu pains champ ich aber an java script kennen wir es nicht vorbeikommen
jquery ja leute ich hab letztens gesehen es gibt ein neues jake einen neuen jquery klon
habe ich letztes auf hacker news gelesen hacker news s query heißt das glaube ich
oder ist das wurde es jquery oder sowas ja die leute bauen immer noch jquery alternativen im
jahr 2022 das verwendet man heute immer noch das ist das ist ja nicht jquery das
ist ja standard browser achso ja heute macht man sowas gar nicht mehr heute verwendet man
tatsächlich eher sowas in dieser richtung wieder ok also service workers habe ich schon verwendet
sowohl sowohl für pwas als auch für multithreading versuche im browser so
habe ich sogar im stream verwendet intel wir haben glaube ich nix bisher irgendwie groß
an translations und sowas gemacht in java script kein webgl webgl haben wir verwendet
tatsächlich webgl haben wir verwendet ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch im c++ web
assembly stream streams waren ja glaube drei stück insgesamt wo wir den video player mit
mit ffm pack und c++ im browser gebaut haben web animations war mir nicht bewusst dass es da
was eigenes für gibt web htc habe ich schon verwendet haben wir sogar im stream was mit
gebaut richtig coole geschichte leider im back end die beste library in go dafür integriert sich
mein restliches ökosystem nicht ganz so gut aber die beste web htc also die beste web htc
anwendung also back end anwendung ist eindeutig diese go library also wenn man ein web htc
fähiges back end beziehungsweise auf serverseite web htc machen will ist das mit abstand die beste
library es gibt eine ganz gute es gibt sip sorcery heißt das das ist für dort nett aber das ist mit
abstand die beste hier also wer web htc machen will auf serverseite beste ich habe die intel
nicht beantwortet doch ich habe gesagt kenne ich nicht web speech habe ich nicht benutzt also
ich weiß dass es so was gibt aber web sockets haben wir benutzt custom elements ja habe ich
auch schon benutzt für home assistant spaß gemacht hat selbst habe ich auch schon benutzt
page visibility api keine ahnung broadcast channel was zum alter was ist denn alles
mittlerweile im browser drinne broadcast channel api api so ein pubs ab im browser oder was es
ist so eine art websocket nur ohne websocket zu sein ok das ist cool das ist cool dass es so
was im browser eingebaut gibt aber nein kenne ich noch nicht geolocation haben wir schon benutzt
falsches mal hier mir auch schon benutzt web share api ne habe ich doch nicht benutzt weiß
ich aber dass es das gibt web xxr device api keine ahnung was das ist wisst ihr was das ist habt
ihr ein plan web xr device api ist das so was wie usb ne augmented reality keckel ne ok next
domain rechte als fisi azubi im zweiten leer ja sinnvoll woher soll ich das wissen ich weiß
noch nicht was die aufgaben für den azubi sind wenn der azubi was in der domäne machen soll dann
soll er auch rechte bekommen sonst kann er ja nichts machen ich kenne weder den azubi noch
kenne ich die aufgaben was soll ich wo wie soll ich das beantworten hier wirklich also keine ahnung
also es gibt azubis den hätte ich es ohne bedenken gegeben im zweiten ja gut ich habe
mit windows und domäne nichts zu tun aber den hätte ich es ohne bedenken gegeben und welche
naja eher nicht so gibt aber auch genug andere leuten den ich nicht geben würde mir würde ich
übrigens auch nicht geben weil ich keine ahnung von windows und domains habe ok ich glaube wir
haben es gleich geschafft die letzte letzten fragen progressive web apps klar aber schon benutzt web
assembly aber auch schon benutzt und es geht weiter leute monke ist das soll ich alles beantworten
ok ach du scheiß ist wenn aber nix machst du nur linux ja macht kein windows ich habe auch ich
gebe auch zu ich habe keine ahnung von windows react not interested buches would use again
angular not interested project not interested emma habe ich mal benutzt will ich nicht mal
benutzen swelt ist äußerst prog elpein habe ich gehört würde ich auch prinzipiell benutzen lit
habe ich schon benutzt würde ich so für custom components auf wiederfinden soll
es interessiert mich finde ich ganz finde ich ganz spannend quick finde ich auch ganz spannend
stencil habe ich keine ahnung was das ist aber nicht overall happiness on a scale of one to five
how happy are you with the current overall state of things related to ehrlich gesagt finde ich web
entwicklung mittlerweile echt nice ja gucken mich jetzt viele ex admins und back end leute
und sonst was komisch an aber ich muss sagen wir macht frontend sachen mittlerweile spaß
wenn rendering frameworks next js nope nukes yup yup mich nicht remix habe ich gehört interessiert
mich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht großartig ersto das würde ich mir tatsächlich gerne mal angucken
alle habe ich noch nie gehört kennt ihr das eleventi die gehört swell kid beste mag ich was ist das
alles das ist eine umfrage zum aktuellen stand der frontend welt also sprich was verwenden die
leute für frameworks was verwenden sie für browser apis was kennen sie was haben sie
schon gehört oder du meinst was das hier alles ist das in javascript frameworks docu saurus
was name alter docu saurus habe ich so basteln ist docu saurus generator in react ok keine noch
nie gehört docu saurus overall happiness wunderbar testing testing überspring ich wir schreiben aus
prinzip keine tests weil unser korn funktioniert immer direkt mobile desktop elektron habe ich
schon benutzt und steinigt mich jetzt nicht ja ich würde elektron zur not auch wenn es sich am
besten eignet für das was ich machen will auch wieder benutzen react native interessiert mich
nicht native apps die native apps die native native apps ist habe ich benutzt würde ich auch weiter
benutzen konto war kenne ich nicht ist das ist das der vorgänger von ionic oder bring ich
jetzt durcheinander ionic ionic ist äußerst nice würde ich gerne mal was damit machen
kapasitor ist der naht mit das hat doch irgendwas hier miteinander zu tun oder
nvgs ogott nvgs habe ich tatsächlich schon mal benutzt will ich aber nicht mehr verwenden das
ist ein bisschen so was wie elektron in die richtung in die richtung expo kenne ich nicht
quasi das ist nvgs framework finde ich interessant habe ich mir schon mal angeguckt habe ich aber
nie was mitgemacht tauri ja warum nicht das ist elektron und mit native browser native script
juckt mich nicht auf all happiness ja wunderbar bildschuls webpack used it would not use again
passe sagt mir was kann ich mich aber nicht mehr genau dran erinnern gulp ogott will ich
nicht mehr verwenden rollup ist auch so ein oldschool ding kann ich mich jetzt interessiert
mich nicht wobei es aber so das habe ich schon gehört das brauche browser ja will ich nicht
mal benutzen tsc cli braucht man das überhaupt noch für typescript aber klar habe ich schon
benutzt würde ich auf jeden fall wenn verteilt rum weiß ich nicht was es ist snowpack sagt mir
was aber keine ahnung svc kenne ich nicht es bild ist das das wenn du npm bild machst bin
ehrlich gesagt relativ ahnungslos gerade keine ahnung beat beste wmr kenne ich nicht turbo pack
ja das ist der neue trend blazing the fast written in rust over all happiness super happy
moos haben erst bald mal oder kann ich mal auf rush kenne ich nicht turbo repo habe ich schon
mal gehört vielleicht interessant jahn workspaces kenne ich nicht jalk kenne ich nicht
lerner kenne ich nicht npm workspaces moment wo sind wir hier monorepo tools keine ahnung
pnpm das kenne ich das ist cool was hat das mit monorepos zu tun was hat pnpm monorepos
pass ich mag sie scharpe auch ist mein abstand lieblingssprache
nx keine ahnung ich habe kein plastenschimmer was ihr von mir wollt libraries ok weiter geht's
which libraries libraries do you use regular regulary party town war das nicht irgend so
ein multiswedding ding für browser oder bring ich das durch alle xjs den rest verwende ich
moment ist standard lip die standard lip oder heißt das ding so was ist das
irgendein standard lip die gar keine standard lip ist hi iq name leute warum nennt man bitte
schön seine library so warum nennt man eine third party library standard library
keine ahnung was auch immer date fms haben wir schon verwendet ja das sage ich dass die
verwende ich eigentlich ganz gerne ja leute ich würde auch ein bisschen mehr erklären dazu ein
bisschen wenn ihr fragen habt dazu was beantworten ich bin jetzt auch nicht irgendwie der hauptberufliche
frontend kenner aber ich muss fertig werden dass ich muss betke demnächst da data visualization
das haben wir letztens verwendet wir haben aber auch schon dj es in letzter zeit verwendet das
war es was haben wir noch mal weiß noch jemand was wir für den für den label champ verwendet
haben es hieß anders um dort die dort dieses grafik tool zu bauen nichts davon data fetching
axios ganz nice apollo klein habe ich oft verwendet für craft craft ql backend frameworks ja es geht
ja nur um javascript sachen und meine backends sind tatsächlich meistens nicht in javascript
utilities nvm ist praktisch ein zx das habe ich schon mal gehört
konva hieß das du hast recht das gab es ja aber nicht zur auswahl bei animation
javascript runtime browser ab und zu mal node weder weder deno noch ban javascript serverless
edge tja ab und zu also netlify habe ich schon verwendet rest als kein javascript functions
flavors ehrlich gesagt ich bin old school vanilla javascript noch nicht mal noch nicht mal groß
typescript non javascript language wieder ist die scharpe nicht auch hier sich die scharp go
python ruby ja wo mache ich eine realistisch betrachtet was drin php eher nicht auch wenn ich
lara will auf die reihe kriege rust würde ich auch kein backend drin machen c++ würde auch kein
backend drin machen in best alda keck wie best wir machen demnächst unser unsere website unser
backend moment best which other languages do you use nicht zwangsläufig für beckens ja gut
hat sie plus plus dabei machen weil ab und zu ist der ein oder andere microcontroller drinnen
usage hamas bald ja wir haben es gleich wir haben es gleich ok how do you divide your time between
javascript 100 prozent javascript verwendet so gut wie gar kein typescript steht demnächst
übrigens auch mal an im stream dass wir uns ein bisschen typescript näher angucken ich habe
typescript schon verwendet so ist es nicht sogar ganz am anfang als es neu war aber irgendwie
aktuell wenig hobby ich bin kein professionell wobei eigentlich leute wenn man es genau nimmt
ich bleib bei hobby ja aber wenn man es genau nimmt ich verdiene indirekt geld mit javascript
ich streame manchmal ein bisschen javascript zeug auf twitch also macht mich das sehr streng
genommen zu einem professionell javascript frontend development das ein oder andere sicherlich
auch backend ab und zu desktop apps mobile apps pvr's und so was graphics an die mächten
game development né né ne né né industrie sektors hin 있으니까 singlepage application
können wir auch machen seltena machen mittlerweile auch partial hydration watering auch progressive
progressive enhancement jetzt wollen es aber wissen streaming s aus er
edge rendering waren wir demnächst auch da ändern wir rendern wir alles
auf keine ahnung
google cloud java script ist moving in the right direction ja tatsächlich finde ich weiß ich wie
jeder seht leute aber ich finde im vergleich zu c++ was sich eher rückwärts entwickelt
entwickelt sich javascript schon die letzten jahre über in die richtige richtung warum nicht
strongly agree weil ich selten diese alles oder also 100 prozent und 0 prozent antworten mag es
gibt bestimmt auch einige sachen wenn ich mir jetzt mal da fünf minuten gedanken drüber machen
würden in mich gehen würde wo ich sag hey das ist was was mir nicht gefällt
building java ist overly complex right now
ja ehrlich gesagt ist es schon
was anderes heutzutage ich mein früher hast du vielleicht jquery benutzt und
hast dann ein bisschen javascript gebaut in dem mehr oder weniger statische html seite das war
easy da hast du dann auch so was wie dreamview dreamweaver gestartet ist das so ich glaube
dreamweaver hieß das macromedia dreamweaver und hast dann das da drin gemacht dann war gut das war
easy du hast den text also heute würde ich schon eher agreeen dass javascript apps nicht so ohne
sind ich meine du brauchst an zeug mit npm installieren du musst irgendwie nen framework
leer also muss müssen muss so muss so nicht aber wenn du moderne web anwendung aufbauen willst
dann schon also ist schon nicht ohne die tools in javascript insgesamt sind dafür finde ich
eigentlich alle recht gut was wahrscheinlich auch daran liegt dass es so viele verwenden und auch
irgendwie mit daran liegt dass es an jeder ecke neues javascript framework gibt das viel ausprobiert
finden sich gute sachen durchsetzen ja guckt euch mal beispielsweise chat okmi genau sieht es aus
guckt euch mal in den projekt an wenn ihr sonst weltkit projekt anlegt oder in den view view
projekt nukes projekt was auch immer da habt ihr alles mögliche lindt konfig typescript konfig
projekt konfig ihr habt ihr habt ohne miss 14 konfig dateien da drinnen javascript öko
ökosystem ändert sich zu schnell da bin ich tatsächlich neutral weil so aus dem bauch aus
würde man sagen eindeutig er kriege aber das ist die letzten jahre etwas anders für die großen
frameworks angular react view und mittlerweile muss man halt auch sagen swell die sind da die
werden auch weiter verbessert die sind aber irgendwo etabliert also es kommt jetzt nicht
wöchentliche neues react oder sowas was das alte dann komplett überflüssig macht wobei gerade
react habe ich jetzt öfter schon gelesen die machen auch ganz gerne mal breaking sachen
ich ich würde sagen ich würde sagen neutral es gibt saumäßig viel neues und ja javascript ist
ja berühmt berüchtigt dafür dass wenn du nicht hinguckst drei neue frameworks gesporn sind
ich würde tatsächlich sagen neutral wie behältst du den überblick gar nicht ich gucke mir ab und
zu github trends an das ist alles und les halt hacker news und ein bisschen auf reddit frontend
development web web def und sonstige sachen les ich halt die subreddits ab und zu aber ansonsten
da geht auch ganz viel an mir vorbei und ich gucke feier schipp videos javascript pain points die
architektur ja bestimmt ein bisschen debugging wir brauchen kein debugger bei uns funktioniert
alles immer dependencies ist tatsächlich ein problem date management ist mittlerweile ganz
brauchbar also ohne scheiß static typing in javascript wäre mega standard library erweitern
könnte man auch pattern matching wäre auch nice nach mehr darf ich nicht machen aber mal so
yo max glaubst du Elon Musk hostet tatsächlich ein youtube video
ach so nett das ist scam meine güte das ist alles scam wie happy ich bin recht gut wie
gesagt wie macht frontend zeug tatsächlich viel spaß auf dem offiziellen tesla kanal kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen dass der youtube video haus sind für das sieht mir nach scam aus
hau happy i was den genuinen skript javascript also ja auch auch gut ich schaue hier im stream
da bestimmt nicht rein resources haben es jetzt bald ja letzte ok das ist das letzte letzte
die mal ausfüllen müssen when first starting out how did you initially learn coding tatsächlich
unter anderem von büchern online kurse so viel free als auch paid videos screencasts
die schule nicht wirklich self directed log magazines hacker news ok ich lese nichts davon
lul which courses der overflow selbstverständlich judy mir habe ich auch schon die anderen sachen
guckt mozilla documentation wie drei schools leider weil sie oben in der google suche drin
sind webpunkt der farb ich früher verwendet verwende ich nicht mehr wie code kamer habe ich
schon sachen geguckt habe ich glaube ich auch noch sachen geguckt das ist der macht die
youtube videos das sagt mir irgendwas o'reilly bücher habe ich letzter zeit keine mehr gekauft
den gucke ich gerne der macht in letzter zeit nicht so viel da ist übrigens auch max der
den channel hier betreibt auf youtube ach hier video creators den gucke ich fire ship gucke ich
das ein oder andere von ihm habe ich auch schon mal geguckt den gucke ich den gucke ich den
gucke ich auch und bei der letzten zeit wenig mal das gucke ich auch manchmal auch den auch ab und
zu auch ab und zu der macht glaube ich wie js videos bin so ein rothaariger glaube ich
ja was program related post podcast ich höre mir so gut wie keine podcast an people
so wir haben es geschafft ich bin 35 bis 44 schlimm oder
jesuf experience nun ja ich bin kein hauptberuflicher frontendentwickler
company size mehr als tausend jährlich salary nein in den wobei mittlerweile wenn ich den
wettest mit dem neuen job da und so oder weiß ja nie aber nein aber ich nicht ich habe nicht
studiert germany gender ich bin ein kerl ein weißer alter heterosexueller omnivore man ganz
schlimm ganz schlimm leute was ich bin das größte weißbrot überhaupt weder noch
ok nice ok gut ja da haben wir jetzt mitgemacht haben was für die allgemeinheit getan schön dass
ihr bei der umfrage mitgemacht habt vom snide haben wir da was gutes getan für heute und
jetzt bettgetheim leute ich zeige euch mal was bettgetheim achtung kleines kleines preview
zu neuen emotes falls ich nicht schon gezeigt habe kleines kleines preview bettgetheim ist
auch nicht final bettgetheim
gut wir sehen uns leute bis denn macht's gut zu